my name is Kathy Guthrie and I'm the
chairman
today this will be the first virtual
planning meeting conducted by mids
District Council and I'm sure you will
understand despite much preparation and
practice there might be a few hiccups
and glitches along the
way I hope you will forgive us for
them with a fair wind and good internet
connection we should be able to
successfully achieve the business of the
day moving
on welcome to this meeting of the
development control B committee the
first virtual meeting conducted by mids
suffk District
Council may I first of all remind you of
some domestic arrangements please ensure
that microphones are muted when you are
not
speaking that you do not interrupt the
other
speaker members are reminded not to use
the messaging chat function during the
meeting unless it is to report a
pecuniary non-pecuniary interest or to
notify the chair that you wish to make a
proposal members are reminded that they
should not have alternative
communication lines open I.E Skype chats
and that if you are contacted by a third
party during an application you should
bring this to the legal advisor's
attention
that if you are attending the meeting to
speak persistently interrupt the meeting
you may be asked to
leave Additionally you will be invited
to speak and ask questions by the chair
of the
meeting please await your
turn I would like to remind everyone
present that this meeting will be
broadcast live to the internet and will
be capable of repeated
viewing the whole of the meeting will be
recorded
except whether are confidential or
exempt
items if you make a representation to
the meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
recorded by entering this meeting as a
speaker you are also consenting to being
recorded by the council and to the
possible use of those sound recordings
for webcasting and or training
purposes the C
members of the public and press May
record film photograph or broadcast this
meeting when the public and press are
not lawfully
excluded during this meeting we will be
also be observing the minute silence at
11:00 a.m. to remember all the health
care and other key workers that have
lost their lives to Corona
virus I will now make the
introductions
Philip Isbell Chief planning officer
sustainable
communities Ian dpre legal
officer Robert carmichel governance
Support
Officer Shan burey senior planning
officer Katherine hail acting senior
planner we also have Teegan Chenery from
Heritage we have counselor Mrs Penny
utton and councelor John
mat we also have members of the
committee and as I move over to the
agenda they will be
introduced we move on to the
agenda apologies for absence and
substitutions thank you chair we don't
have any at the moment however we have
just been aw made aware that Council
Norris has dropped out from from a power
cut um
so I would um I believe that my
colleague Mandy is just trying to
reconnect with him but um so he cannot
join at the moment so it's chair if you
would it's up to yourself whether we
want to wait and see if we can reconnect
him or to carry on um where
possible um I think if at this moment as
it is purely the um the agenda we can
carry on because we're moving very
closely to the 11:00 when we will have a
minute
silence um if I may Madam chairman I I
agree I think it's obviously councelor
Norris can't participate in any business
that he hasn't heard but if we um in
it's if we can carry on with the
formalities and hope we can reconnect
him quickly I I agree with
that thank you for that
help so there were no apologies ask for
just go back to that point Thank
you and so would you do a roll call of
the members present
please thank you chair so councelor
James
carsten present councelor Peter
G
present councilor
Guthrie yes I'm here councel
Humphries president councelor
melon
present councilor Norris as we have
covered um just now um just been also
informed that it's a quite a large power
cut in the whole NM area so we'll come
back to that shortly um so councelor
Stringer president councel War boys
presentent Council
mat president and councelor
Aon and I notice um for item two to
receive Declarations of pecuniary and
non-pecuniary interest by members and
councelor
Stringer would you like to speak on your
declaration uh well the details are all
in the in the Declaration uh my
brother-in-law lives along uh mil Road
at buckel in Crown cottage which is
listed on one of the maps it's it's it's
not close to the proposed development
but it is in the same road so I declare
that just in the interest of
transparency that's very helpful thank
you
counselor Declarations of
lobbying there would appear to be
none Declarations of personal site
visits again there appear to be
none confirmation of the minutes of the
meeting held on the 4th of March and
members have had a copy of these minutes
so are there any points of
accuracy that need
amending there would appear to be none
can I have a proposal for the minutes
please
please happy to propose the minutes
James
Casten thank you for that and can I have
a seconder
please happy to Second uh the minutes C
Peter gold thank you for that Robert can
you now do a roll call just for the
approval of the minutes
please thank you chair so if you could
please answer for against or abstain so
councelor James car
four councelor Peter
gold four councelor
Guthrie four councel
humre four councelor
melon four councelor Norris as we
actually sorry apologies not here for
that part councelor
Stringer four and Council of all
boys po so that is carried chair you
unanimously thank you for that the
minutes of the meeting have been
confirmed and will be signed at the next
practicable
opportunity item six to receive
notification of petitions in accordance
with council's petition scheme none
received
chair the schedule of the planning
applications I propose will be taken in
the following order item 7B
dc19
05761 land to the south of milroad
buckel where penny oton is the ward
member councelor uton is the ward member
and the second one will be 7A dc1 180
4491 land adjacent to buckel Lodge
buckel Road great finb and councelor
maton is the ward
member can we just pause at this point
and find if we have got councel Norris
back in any way shape or form can he
join by his mobile phone to the
meeting I'll just ask my colleague now
also just to not is that the supporter
Dr David hickey has also dropped out so
we'll try and reestablish connection
with him as
well
I wonder if we should now pause the live
streaming because we are heading to
9:55 and we do have a couple of problems
with uh people um able to be in the
meeting and we will be heading to the
11:00 um in dee do you agree with that
approach I think it's ch it's 10:00
first before we have
is oh it's the 11:00 meeting I beg your
pardon yes you're quite right um just to
not as well count Dr David hickey has
just rejoined count uh Dr hickey could
you please um make yourself known that
you can hear us and that you can speak
to the meeting
please
Robert can you just try and confirm with
Dr hickey again do you have an
alternative contact for him yes well I
don't have an alternative contact
however um we do have the dialing
um do have the dial in as well if I just
unmute Dr hiy first just to check
so Dr hickey can you hear us now could
you please respond if
possible no
okay if I if I may come in we definitely
unmuted Dr hickey he's definitely he's
not accidentally muted all right okay
thank you I unmuted the microphone there
in that instance as well what I will now
ask is
um if I set I will send Dr hickey an
email basically so if you can't hear if
you can hear us now then oh we've got a
guest now in yes is that Dr hickey h
Hello ah brilliant hello I'm here
brilliant thank you very
much the only person when you're
not sorry Robert you were going to say
um I was just going to say the only
other person that we can't establish
connection to now is councelor
Norris but can um Dr hickey now mute his
microphone please because it needs to be
muted until you need to speak I'm on the
phone so I don't know what to do that's
right I can control that chair from
here so thanks so much right thank
you um so Ian we've still lost um
councelor Norris what would your advice
be Madam chairman I yes I think um
possib yes we we've got some time to
spare if I can use that word before the
um three the the the silence at 11:00
it's 11 o' not 10 o00 my mistake yeah so
my mind too I I think we yeah we we need
I mean I know it's it kind of um well
these things are bound to happen I think
we should perhaps if if we do pause the
live stream and spend a little time um
Robert can try and see if we can
possibly reconnect counselor Norris if I
mean if the if this power cut is is a
lot of people for a little while in need
them we may have to lose him at least
for one item but I think Robert if my
colleague Robert with M other colleagues
help could see if there's any means of
reconnecting councelor Norris as you
know by mobile phone or or whatever we
we'll have can can I comment on on this
uh chairman indeed yes I'm looking I'm
looking separately at the UK power
Network website which notes uh quite a
wide area of power power cut in the area
of needen Market that refers to the
disruption and estimates the power we
back on between 11: and
12:00 um can I just have in D pra's
legal guidance when we were um given the
permission to do these live streaming is
there anything that covers um this
unfortunate situation and that we can
carry on could I ask Ian if he's looked
at the instructions I don't I think
chairman I don't think that the the law
hasn't altered the basic principles of
the members being present and when
they're not when if they're late for an
item or miss or don't hear some of it
they they they can't vote on it I think
it just it just the the the new
legislation simply allows us to do
things by um you know inter by internet
and phone and Etc and video Skype Etc so
I think if the I was just thinking if um
if I think it was being suggested that
that councelor Norris might have a
mobile that would um not need um as it
were landl line
infrastructure but if I mean if we can I
just think we we we I think Rob's think
thinking was we shouldn't Rob at Mr
Carmichaels thinking was we shouldn't um
lead councelor Norris out unless we're
absolutely sure we've lost him for the
next hour or so but I don't know if it's
possible to establish that in a couple
of minutes without you know delaying the
meeting
unduly yes I'm I'm quite happy as
chairman to suspend the meeting for a
short while while we try and get
reconnection with councelor Norris and
Mr isbel you were about to speak could
you com comment on that please uh yeah
happy about that chairman just wondering
if it's useful if I try and make contact
with him separately and didn't know
whether you were trying to do that or or
whether Mandy was doing that
Robert hello it's Mandy yeah I've just
spoken to councelor Norris and he has
spoken to UK power and um is not
expecting his power to be back on until
after 11:00 so he wishes the meeting to
go on without
him
can we not get connection from him off
his mobile
phone um because he hasn't got access to
his computer he hasn't got access to the
dialing numbers
either um which are on the uh email well
I'm sure somebody could ring them
through as well can you email one of the
officers in to to ring him through with
the details to see if he could rejoin
Robert what do you think of that
if it's possible chair and if he's happy
to then then I don't that that's fine by
myself um if we if we set a time then of
if we say if we give it until 1010 and
then we start then if we haven't made
Connection by that point that we will
continue business does that sound
reasonable
chair yes that sounds reasonable I just
think that we should make every effort
at the moment please so if you'd like to
suspend the live stream y I will mute
all participants until 1010 um as I
can't exactly pause it um so I'll just
mute all participants until that
point thank
you
for
e
is
right thank you very much so we
reconvene um would you like to just
explain um the situation with councelor
Norris and his response please thank
you
thank you very much indeed so we now
move to the uh first item of the day
under dc19
05761 land to the south of milroad
buckel and I will now invite case
officer Shan banre to introduce the
application to the committee please
thank you
Shan thank you
chair I'm now going to present my
application and prepare the
PowerPoint
thank you Robert are you able to confirm
that the slideshow is available for
view
okay okay thank you very
much first of all I would just like to
draw members attention to the tabled
paper um which has been presented which
is the uh most recent refusal for the
planning application on this site which
is referen
dc19
3352 and I hope members have that in
front of them so I'll continue with the
presentation the application is for the
erection of an off-grid sustainable
dwelling with parking Landscaping a
sewage treatment plant and improved
access a garage and
Annex the agent has confirmed that the
proposal incorporates the use of
electric cars with the availability of a
log solar panels a Tesla power and
battery storage for you for using the
solar electricity at night a heat
recovery system and ground Source heat
pump the slide in front of us puts the
site marked um with pink hatching in the
the village of Buel and the application
side in its context with uh great finra
off to the right and the town of Stow
Market a a couple of miles further east
again the application site is shown
edged in
red and this fronts Mill Road in
buckel there are two public right of
ways one which runs to the west of the
application site and down from Mil road
to brettenham
Road and a further public right of way
which again runs to the east from Mil
road down to the church and Beyond
further south to brettenham
Road this application before us today is
the third for development on this site
the most recent application is the one I
just referred to in terms of the tabled
papers and that was for the same site
edged in
red that application was refused and is
currently at
appeal the first application on the site
dc18
05321 that extended the site further
east to this public foot path and was
for the whole of the road Frontage onto
this Open Meadow and paddock Land which
lies east of the current application
site again putting the site in a little
bit more
context I've shown here a site uh
opposite the site to the Northeast where
two previous applications dc18
02098 and one
22617 for two and three dwellings were
refused and those appeals were dismissed
and reference is made to those
applications in the main body of my
report they're also referred to um by
the comments which you've received from
the Heritage team in terms of discussing
the sustainability of this location and
the setting of listed
buildings the site here shows the
application site in the context of
nearby listed
buildings generally grade two which are
marked in
Orange a two Star Building over to the
east at mapole farm and the the grade
one
Church the constraints map again shows
the uh dwellings the listed buildings uh
the presence of protected species and
the hatched area is a zone for wider
consideration of the impact on uh more
distant sites of special scientific
interest the green area here is the whsh
safeguarding area for development for uh
of large of tall buildings and the flood
risk potential for surface water
flooding which is just on the Frontage
Pond but not on the main
site the aerial map shows the uh
landscape character uh the Open Meadow
and padic land to the east agricultural
land further to the west and the South
with the listed building ings previously
referred to which are north and east of
the
site and in The Wider context you can
see the slightly larger builtup area of
buckel in this location here the
church uh the commercial premises of
Tomlinson ground care and the larger
part centered around mil green um
further part of Buel
the slide shows the proposed site layout
with the main
dwelling orientated East West roughly
with a one-bedroom Annex above which is
set approximately 25 M back from the
highway the application involves the
upgrading of this existing vehicular
access a new hedge to the eastern
boundary of the
site Orchard planting further
east a proposal for barn and bat boxes
around the site and for shading around
the pond here to be cleared to encourage
NES to lay
eggs the elevations for the proposal
indicate a barn style barn style
dwelling with black chard boarding on
the
roofs and continuing
down with red brick work on the ground
floor and also on the
enclosing walls um described as a fold
yard
wall which encloses the private Garden
area and clear story Windows reinforce
the floating appearance
of the first
floor 48 photovoltaic panels are shown
on the south roof of the garage Annex
Building the main house has a ridge
height of
m 5177 m to the eaves and this enclosed
wall is 2.1 M
High
the next elevations which are described
as closed and that refers to the
shuttering to the first floor windows
and the appearance of The Proposal when
those windows are covered
over so looking at the proposed floor
plans we have the ground floor and the
first
floor
separating them out the ground floor
plan again you can see the walls which
enclose the private Garden area and the
main dwelling here has an open plan a
main living and kitchen area a pantry
and utility room a study hallway and
snug and over in the garage building uh
there are three uh garage spaces a hobby
room and then space for bin store and
logs the first floor plans again on the
main dwelling this shows five bedrooms
two of which are on
suite and the one-bedroom Annex has an
open plan living and kitchen area with a
deck
area
the next slide shows the elevations in a
little bit more
detail on this Gable elevation here it
shows a single black metal chimney
flu simple vertical charred Timber black
boards to the
walls the Gable
proportions and the matching barns are
intended to replicate common suffk
proportion of Barns and fold yard
groupings there are deliberately no roof
lights to avoid a domestic
appearance and here you can see the
sliding
shutters which are to hide the domestic
appearance of the building and make the
home look like a more agricultural
character the glazing generally is
simple and large to appear
non-domestic and the red brick wall is
proposed to have lime colored mortar and
a double sold your course at the
top the basement plan shows a link
between the house and the annex and
which provid for uh plant room and
storage of wine and
batteries and here we have a section
through part of the proposed
dwelling plan provided by the agent
shows the site here in its wider Village
context the applicants family business
at Tomlinson ground care is in this
location here and we have the church
the two public foot paths I've referred
to and Village
dwellings uh public
house uh the applicant refers to an
appeal decision up here for a single
dwelling permission that was granted
here for uh four dwellings I understand
and further Residential
Properties uh some submitted uh 3D views
to give an indication
of um how the proposal would
look can I just interrupt Sean I believe
councelor mat has a bit of a problem um
with his um internet connection uh could
uh Robert carmichel advis us of this
please just one moment Sean if you would
please yes certainly so councilor
mathson can you see the presentation
before
us no that's the exact thing
unfortunately I'm getting the audio fine
um but it I'm get when I look when I
open Johan's desktop it's unfortunately
black
blank okay I don't think you should be
opening Shan's desktop it it would have
just automatically come up am I correct
Robert it should have automatically just
come up yeah um perhaps if we try one
thing is if if sha closes her desktop
and reopens it perhaps that might um if
you don't mind Sean that would be most
helpful um so that we can just ascertain
that everyone um can see
it okay I'll end the
slideshow and from what I can see it's
it's as the papers we've got um and that
councelor Matson should not be opening
anything just watching it I presume is
that correct I would I would love to be
watching it I know you would but if you
can just if you can just let the screens
do the work for you at the moment yeah
yeah no I'm I'm there's a thing called
manage content and I I just tried to um
to you know I've just been trying
switching that on and off and so on but
all I'm getting is is Sean's desktop
blank yeah let's see see what happens
cancer if you would I'm watching I'll
turn the audio off
now I'll I'll try and open it and share
the content
again
can you see my screen
Robert yes hello yes thank you
C
MTH
so just is there anyone that whil we're
on the top of that is there anyone that
can't currently
um I'll take that sence I think if
unless cancel meth and if you want to
say that you can't see it I would say
that we continue and there's any
references to the papers we could go
um look back at that
possibly can I can I suggest that if uh
Sean is able to cross reference to or or
we are able to cross reference to the
pages of the agenda paper so that
Council M can hear which uh which slide
we're referring to what what what
drawings um then there shouldn't be uh
disadvantage I agree with
that thank you in terms of the
presentation I've now reached um uh some
the photographs around the
site should I continue to the
photographs um I think if you just go
back to um just before one one stage
before just one page before the thing so
that councel M can pick it
up
well that just go back on and just pick
up your comments on the previous slide
page 18 and then councelor mat I'm sure
you can hear
that yes this again is a slide um a
document uh site um context plan
provided by the agent which shows you
sorry Sean that slide
that's slide 14 page 174 for counselor
mat if you can look at that sorry about
that oh sorry I haven't got the
um no that's all right you carry on
that's fine it's okay yeah so this is
just this is the site in context again
um the application site here the Tom
linson's family business to the South
the church and residential development
and then in into the P the public house
into the core of development uh in
buckel and then I move on to uh some of
the agents proposed 3D
views and then I have some of my
photographs of the site um the first
photographs here were taken back in
January um on a slightly gloomy day um
towards the end the presentation I have
some brighter photographs which were
taken in connection with the previous
applications on the site um and those
are more of a a summer and a brighter
view just to give a little bit more
information so generally the site here
shows the approach towards the frontage
of the site um with the frontage
hedge and this is the frontage of the
site and you can see a pond here just to
the side of the road
and the access is in this location
here so this is the access into the site
which is proposed to be um altered to
serve the
dwelling and a view into the application
site from the existing field
access so this is looking
South again a view of the existing
vehicular
access and this is the public foot path
the entrance the public foot path which
runs down the western boundary of the
site again a view behind these white
railings of the frontage Pond which has
been referred to and the
vegetation looking across the pond into
the
site and A View From the roadside over
towards buckel church Tower
so here we have the frontage of the site
on the right hand side of the photograph
and uh two of the listed buildings which
are in the vicinity of the site fronting
Mill
Road this photograph is taken from the
footpath which runs um North South along
the eastern boundary of the land so the
land in the foreground is that which
would now be excluded from the
application site
um with the proposed hedge boundary
roughly in this location here and the
application site itself is over uh the
far side of this Paddock Field
Land again looking from the application
uh from the public foot path towards
north and milroad and you can see some
of those listed buildings opposite the
site and some of the more recent tree
planting which has been undertaken um in
the this area that's to be retained as
Meadow again looking over towards the
site I'm afraid that one's a little bit
dark but you can see hedging on the
southern boundary and the Hedge that
runs along the western
boundary this is part of the southern
boundary of the
site and a view from that same public
footpath towards the Tomlinson Lawn Care
buildings which are at the rear of the
site
this then is looking further north back
towards mil Road and the application
site is the other side of this hedge in
this location
here this is copinger hall or the old
rectory ajacent to buckel church and
again this is the view from the public
foot
path we're back at mil road now and this
is the entrance to the public foot path
that runs along the Eastern bound uh
eastern boundary of the site to buckel
church with these two listed buildings
over looking the Meadowland and
application
site so some slightly brighter uh
summertime views this is the rear
boundary of the
site this is looking across the site
from that Eastern public
footpath one of the adjacent properties
up towards mil Road looking over the
site properties in mil Road looking
towards the application
site Frontage of the
application again a property in mil Road
opposite the
site and this is a barn um uh opposite
the site here and the public footpath
sign post which runs down the eastern
boundary
the meadow to the rear of the
application site with distant views
there of the church
Tower this is the western boundary of
the site uh taken from the public
footpath and again we're back to the
application
site I think the thing to point out uh
chairman is that this is the and it's
referred to in the papers uh that this
is the third app application on this
site both of which previously have been
refused and the most recent application
as I say has gone to committee and this
is highlighted in the
report the difference with the current
application from the previous one is
that the ridge height has been reduced
by
0.5 M and there's some more clarity over
proposed planting in the retained
Meadowland the main context for
discussion here really is the setting of
those adjacent listed buildings uh the
open Nature and Landscape character of
the site and the contribution that that
makes to the locality and the setting of
the listed buildings and then in the
conclusion of my report I refer to the
need for the planning balance um and
weighing any adverse impacts um against
the benefits of The
Proposal uh the proposal has been
assessed to cause a medium level of less
than substantial harm to the listed
buildings and that needs to be balanced
against the public
benefits but it's felt uh that the
proposal uh harms the character of the
setting of the listed buildings and its
rural context and the recommendation is
one of refusal thank you
thank you
chair thank you for that Sean just one
correction there you said it's gone to
committee it's actually gone to the
appeal inspector slip of the tongue I
think sorry the previous refusal yes is
currently at appeal right um we need to
um move on to the um questions from
members but before we do just to pick up
on a point you've made there that and
the Heritage um knows about um the uh
issues regarding Heritage and there does
seem to be a difference of opinion
between the applicants and the um our
own Heritage officer and so um we do
have um a supporter we have the
architect and agent and we also have the
ward member so all these May well be
drawn out in there so we will now go um
to the questions from members and I will
go down the counselors in an
alphabetical order asking if they have
questions for um Sean so counselor
Casten do you have a question for Sean
please thank you very much chair yes I
just wanted to um
clarify when a um log was mentioned with
the electrical vehicle um provision that
the house came with I I don't know what
a log is I assume it's not the log that
I'm thinking of uh
chair um can you hear me okay yes yeah I
I think the uh the offer there is that
the agent that the applicants um would
offer to keep a record of the use of
their electric vehicles and and
confirmation that that they um are going
to utilize the electric vehicles as they
are proposing to do and if we wanted to
check that uh that they were undertaking
that um then then a log of use would be
available or a log of ownership would be
available
oh okay thank you very much um on slide
four on the map it's a um it's a
flooding um map um so down at the I
assume it's the South End there's the um
Tomlinson's ground care site and on
there they're marked poultry houses um
are they actually um poultry houses or
are they part of the Tomlinson ground
care um um site there I haven't been to
that particular site but as far as I'm
aware those are um old poultry houses
and that they have now been Incorporated
together with new build into the uh the
Tomlinson's um
operation and we have to be careful that
we're talking about this site um so just
make sure we stay on track with that if
you would please yeah no I I was just
thinking of the houses proximity to um
livestock sheds and the um environmental
implications like with flies and things
like that but I'm pretty sure looking at
Google Earth that that's not the case
it's just the um it's the maps wrong
that we've got here um but no no further
questions thank you thank you councelor
Casten now I'll ask does councelor gold
have any questions
please uh no no questions for me thank
you
chair thank you counselor councelor
Humphries any questions yes Madam chair
just one please um can the officer
confirm that the agent has agreed the
affordable housing contribution of
26577 50 P
please the affordable housing
contribution has been agreed uh but the
obligation uh hasn't been um entered
into yet to sign that but verbally and
in writing they've agreed that they will
undertake
that thank
you and ccor melon do you have a
question
please
uh no questions
chair thank you for that and councelor
Stringer do you have a question please
for the
officer um yes chair I'm afraid I have
several uh can I uh be told it's very
difficult from the plans to work out how
uh the size of the dwelling could I ask
how many square meters of living space
including the annex this this
development is asking for could I also
ask why our sustainability officer
hasn't commented uh the application is
for a quote off-grid dwelling offgrid
means not using public
utilities uh I don't have any details of
water how how the water is going to be
captured and and used uh or if they're
going to sink a well or what they're
going to do uh and that would have been
very helpful to had the comments of the
officer that we employ to comment on
sustainability
matters
um I also have a question about the
power
uh could I be told how many kilowatt
hours are coming off the solar panels
and how many in the power wall uh
because there seems to be a
mismatch uh thank you chairman um I'm
afraid I probably not going to be able
to answer those questionss immediately
certainly in terms of the square meter
of the living space I would probably
have to hunt around and see if that
information is before me um the agent is
here I don't know whether he might have
that information um if he's given that
opportunity um the sustainability
officer is generally not consulted for a
single dwelling um and indeed hasn't
been consulted in this particular case
um um and again the details of the uh
Power use I'm afraid I haven't got those
at my
fingertips thank you perhaps we can ask
the applicant on that sort of
information councel Stringer would that
be
helpful councelor
Stringer sorry I'm surprised I I can't
see why we don't ask the sustainability
officer when the development is larg
enough to trigger an affordable housing
contribution well that will be for your
consideration and debate later on you've
asked the question which is really
helpful so um perhaps you can ask the
question of the size of the applicant he
might be working on it now as we speak
so apart from that have you finished
with that because these are questions
not the debate thank
you councelor War boys do you have
questions of the officer
no no
[Music]
questions and I don't have any questions
for the
officer
so moving
on we now have have a
supporter who would like to speak we
don't have any Representatives oh
actually just coming back councelor uton
did you have any questions for the
officer coun no questions M um Madame
chairman right thank you for that sorry
I didn't mean to miss you out um so we
don't have any representatives from the
parish counil or an objector um but we
do have a supporter Dr David hickey and
you have three minutes
um to address the committee if you just
wait for a moment where Sean will get
the three minute uh timer up on the
screen and um we we will wait until
you've said good morning and that we've
got you in in our radar here and then
the three minutes you will see it
ticking across the screen thank you good
morning Mr Dr
hickey my name is Dr David hickey I'm a
heritage consultant and I was formerly
assistant Regional director at historic
England I'm a national expert on the
settings of historic buildings the
proposals have been carefully designed
and located to create a new contemporary
style sustainable residence in the
village of Buel which respects the
village rural setting the pro proposals
also ensure that the setting of the
nearby listed buildings are not
adversely affected the historic England
guidance on determining the setting of
Heritage assets states that setting is
the surroundings in which the asset is
experienced May therefore be more
extensive than its curage this clearly
suggests that for many Heritage assets
this will will only be the curtilage but
many will also include an extended area
around the the asset where the Heritage
asset will be experienced the guidance
in no way suggests that this area of the
setting will be an extensive area it has
to be the area where it is experienced
and this area can settings area can
change over time we carefully identified
the setting of each of the nearby listed
buildings and map the extent of these
settings in accordance with the national
guidelines in the light of this Heritage
setting assessment we slightly relocated
the footprint of the house to ensure
that that it clearly lies outside the
settings of the nearby listed
buildings it is regrettable that your
heritage staff attending a training
course where they were misinformed of
how to assess such settings after seeing
the Heritage team's assessment of the
site we contacted historic England who
confirmed in writing the Heritage team's
misunderstanding and we've provided you
a copy of this letter we accept that
there will be changes within the
immediate locality of the proposed new
house the western part of the field will
change from current open Grace pasture
to one of refined domestic character the
main intimate Garden spaces around the
wall within the wall will be kept to the
southern side of the uh the building
this allows the views from the sites
from the the north to be simply from the
house or to be simply of the house set
within a larger area of trees and
grassland however most of these views
will be screened from the road by the
existing hedro and additional trees the
new native hedro separating The Garden
of the meadow will delate the change
from domestic worlder Garden to the open
grassland on the eastern half of the
field which will be very much as it is
at present the settings of the nearby Li
stick buildings will not be adversely
affected there will be no Heritage
impact on other nearby Heritage assets
the development there on balance does
not directly conflict with any local
National policies thank
you
thank you Dr hickey and now I will go to
everyone to ask questions um for you so
first of
all councelor Casten do you have any
questions for Dr
hickey am I allowed to ask whether he's
a um member of the public or whether
he's been employed by the applicant yes
you can I'd like to ask that
please yes I'm the Heritage consultant
thank you very much no further
questions councelor
gold thank you councelor kaston has just
asked my question thank you thank you
councelor
Humphries no questions thank you
melon uh no
question councelor
Stringer no
questions and councelor War
boys sorry yes just switch my mic uh yes
just just the to clarify did you
consider the settings of the listed
buildings individually or was the
accumulative um context of those
different
settings uh can you hear me yes yeah
sorry about that yes a very good
question yes we did so I started off
within individual uh mapping for each
individual one and then put them all
together and then this reveals that
actually the site lined in red was
outside uh the the the building and the
the Garden area was outside of all these
settings okay thank you thank you
councilor BOS and thank you um Dr hickey
for that and I don't have any further
questions so thank you very much Dr
hickey um if you would now like to um
mute your microphone thank you and I
will ask the agent Craig beach to speak
and you will have three minutes and
again you'll see the timer going across
the screen if you would please we are
approaching I have to say the 11:00 very
shortly but um I'm sure there's time for
your three minutes Mr Beach thank you
okay can you hear me okay yes good okay
I'll start good morning this application
will enable a family group who have
lived in and grown a rural Horticultural
business in books for over 30 years to
remain together within their Community
with the exception of the Heritage
issues all consules have no objections
to the scheme as noted by the district
councelor the parish have fully
supported the scheme until recently the
design of the house provides a truly
unique and exceptional home both
architecturally and sustainably whilst
being located a short 100 meter walk
from the family business it is
innovative as this is the first time
that all the renewable Technologies and
materials have been used together in a
house the cars in the house will be
fully electric and charged via onsite
electricity production and battery
storage all walls floors and roof are
highly insulated to passive house
standards the council's own
sustainability officer fully supports
the scheme and states that its
sustainable aims have been clearly
demonstrated there are two
recommendations for refusal listed by
the planning officer firstly affordable
housing the applicant has previously
confirmed they are happy to agree a
contribution to affordable housing and
this has been confirmed by Shan secondly
the impact on historic setting the
client's heritage expert Dr David hickey
has responded to these concerns
confirming that the impact is minimal
and acceptable the creation of a black
barn of traditional shap and form is
something to be entirely expected within
the suffk landscape and is a common site
in Heritage settings as such this new
dwelling will not detract it will simply
appear as a barn conversion within the
village and a subtle
Evolution the dwelling has been
carefully designed fit within this
context it is distant from Heritage
assets some 200 meters from the grade
one church with inter Ving trees hedge
roads field and foot path it is 45 minut
meters from Sawyers the nearest gry to
list the building again with mature
trees Pond Road and hedging between the
two cannot see each other in summer or
winter thus its impact is minimal and
certainly not harmful as can be seen on
site in photographs and from the plans
The Proposal hiden is hidden by existing
hedging and trees its height has also
been reduced in response to the
council's Heritage
concerns the site is currently a disused
paddock not farmland
a detailed Landscaping scheme is
provided as part of the application with
significant new planting further hiding
the development from View and
significantly enhancing the biodiversity
of the site and encouraging
wildlife in summary this is a truly
unique and exceptional scheme there are
no objections from the sustainability
officer environmental health highways
suff Wildlife trust Natural England or
historic England the government have
indicated we need a million new homes
why not build at least one that is
innovative architecturally outstanding
highly sustainable and addresses the
challenges of climate change whilst
providing a much valued home for a local
family in housing need who run a
successful Village business thank
you thank you for that um I'm conscious
of time so we're still all right here at
the moment um can I ask um questions um
for the um Craig beach councelor Casten
no questions chair thank you councelor
gold uh no questions thank you
chair councelor
humph no questions thank you
melon councelor melon any questions yes
thank you chair I have a couple um I'd
like to ask the uh the applicants agent
um just to sort of explore further this
idea of the house being off grid can he
just sort of confirm that there will be
no electricity connection to the grid
and what is the situation with the sort
of
water uh that's one question the other
question I just wanted to ask is from
the plans it seems that there is a path
sort of leading southwards towards the
The Business site is it sort of an
intention to create a sort of Track Way
directly from this site all the way up
to Thomas and ground care itself
if I do I'll do with the first uh item
um the the water it's planed to sink a
ball Hole uh and that will be for all
water on site so the idea is it's an
off-grid dwelling um and the second
question in terms of the path yes the
applicants um both work within the
family business and their daily commute
will be across the land that they own um
Turned from the business which is about
100 meters to the South
on
foot thank
you uh thank you for that um actually
we're approaching the five the uh 54
minutes and I've just lost my screen for
some unknown
reason um I wonder how we can get that
back let's
see there we are got it back um
um councelor Stringer do you want to
hold your question for the moment um
because or will you be able to conclude
the questions in five
minutes I think that might be a struggle
chair U I've still got all the
outstanding questions from the officer
to
answer um well I know um Philip Isbell
can um come in on one of the questions
you had earlier philli would you like to
just put your point across on that
please uh thank you chairman yes councel
string I think you asked about the power
output of the solar panels um from what
I can see uh on the application
form uh the uh application describes an
output from uh 48 I think 320 W panels
being
15.36% I understand it the uh you asked
about inter about internal FL living
space didn't you I understand it from
the S form and I haven't viewed this uh
direct but colleagues advise me I
understand the internal floor space to
that is 461 Square met described on our
seal form thank you
chairman thank you for that um I do
think we should just suspend the meeting
for the moment now because we are
marking down um to the 56 1056 what what
does our legal officer recommend before
I ask councelor Stringer to continue
with his questions good hello Madam
chair yes I I see yes it's a practical
point that we can't I mean unless um I
don't know if we can just do do you want
to maybe if councelor Stringer wants to
put a question and then we just we'll
just suspend it then because we unless
the answers are very quick right pleas
so councelor string if you just ask one
question we've got three minutes and we
can make a note of that and then we can
um just take our um period of Silence
thank
you councelor Stringer you have a
question just the one question you were
going to ask and then we'll just hold
for the answer yes I I will do the the
power generation then in an 8 hour day
uh if we get eight hours of sunshine
that's 22 kilow but there's only 27
kilowatt hours of storage proposed so
I'm not quite sure what happens with the
Excess power
uh um okay Madam chair I heard that and
perhaps shall we just if counselor
Stringer has another question shall we
note them down and then we can answer
them methodically when after the Silence
has been observed is that all right
we've got one more minute maybe yes go
for it councelor Stringer if you would
please yes I will it relates to a
question I asked earlier in that the
agent was quoting from the our
sustainability officer uh but we haven't
seen that that
guidance so I've noted that and also do
you have another
question councelor stranger sorry uh
sorry sorry if you're writing it out or
working it out um yeah sorry because
obviously as I start getting answers on
it's ask answering the questions I don't
have any more uh today right and I think
at that juncture before we get your
response um can we now just um I think
Robert you would actually stop the live
streaming or are you just going to leave
it going and just mute everybody's
microphones Robert carmichel sorry sorry
chair um yep that's what I do I'll just
do mute everyone's
microphones if you do that for us and we
observe just slightly longer but if you
can just do that for us now thank you
yes
e
thank you very much everybody and I'm
sure we were all very conscious of the
people for whom we were
respecting so um can we move on now and
um have um councelor stringer's question
the first one was what happens to the
Excess power please um and that is for
um Mr Beach thank
you
for
[Music]
hello can you hear
me hello hello Mr Beach I can hear
you yes we can hear you now yeah I
couldn't turn the mute off sorry about
that it was just stuck for a second
apologies I think that was myself
um okay thanks um so uh yeah first
question I think um sustainability
officer actually yes uh on this
application wasn't consulted I think um
previous
applications uh was consulted and I
think by a different planning officer
granted um and I think they didn't raise
any issues at that time um I think the
question can we just stick with the
question please which was what happens
to the Excess power I think that was the
I think there were two oh the yeah but I
don't want you to debate I mean it's
just um oh no I just there was a
question about this that was the
sustainability officer consulted as part
of the second question sorry well that
would be for the officer I think rather
than your fine okay um uh yeah so the
second question about power yes there's
um 48 panels shown um the power that's
generated by those is likely to be
slightly better now the the efficiency
of panels increases all the time um
there are if you look at page 22 of our
design and access statements it shows a
diagram from Tesla who've been consulted
about how much battery storage would be
needed and that confirms three power
wall units um based on the energy use of
the dwelling uh and the excess
electricity um the other part of um
councelor stringer's question that will
go to Via a system called a Smart Switch
which will use the electricity to run
the ground Source heat pump uh and
mechanical ventilation heat recovery
system with excess electricity being
stored by the power wall system so uh
gains from the electricity generators on
site will be Amplified by the ground
source and the mechanical ventilation
heat recovery system as well as
electricity being stored in the power
wall units um so the calculations that
Tesla have done with us show if you look
at page 22 that the house will be 100%
self-powered by having three of these
units along with the amount of
photovoltaic shown and including
electrical charging equipment for the
cars thank you for that um and um
councelor Stringer you did you did sort
of ask the agent for sustainability but
I think that really is a question for
the officer I mean clearly the agent has
given a response that it was done before
and not now we've got all the papers
here um did you want to um just ask the
officer one more question about that
we'll do that in a minute or do you have
another question um the um applicant
yeah yeah yes I do actually he didn't
answer my question about the power
generation he answered that three power
walls would power the house but the
power generation is far in excess of
what those batteries can
store uh he is he is suggesting that it
well then the Excess power will be
running the heat recovery and the heat
pump those will be running anyway the
heat recovery system will be running 24
hours a day um councelor Stringer can I
ask you to make an assessment on this
because we're going really in depth into
something you know I think you've got to
make an assessment yourself the agent
hasn't given you the response you want
so we can't just keep having a debate on
it you have to make your assessment the
the the other the other question I have
for the agent is what what Innovations
of the building what are the foundations
made of that's very useful question and
perhaps Mr be can answer that for us yes
certainly so the um foundation of the
building is effectively what's called a
thickened raft um which is uh generally
a a European system a German system um
so it's a Concrete raft that doesn't
have deep foundations it sits like a
thick and lab to give you thermal mass
for an energy efficient
dwelling thank you for that and um are
they all your questions councelor
Stringer uh yes thank you thank you
thank you very much councelor War boys
any questions for Mr
Beach no no questions thank you thank
you counselor and myself I don't have
any further questions for Mr Beach but
what I would like to do is just to
invite um Teegan um who's our heritage
officer to respond perhaps to some of
the um issues regarding the Heritage um
we've got quite a lot of paperwork from
her so would you like to just um make
some comment on issues that have been
raised
please yes thank you chair um just to
respond basically um I think the fun
fundamental difference between uh the
heritage teams assessment and the
Heritage Consultants assessment is the
extent of the setting of the listed
building so fundamentally we feel that
the proposal site does fall within the
setting of many of the Heritage assets
um it's clearly a dense cluster of
listed buildings to the north Northeast
East and southeast of The Proposal site
um it's in a rural location and we feel
that the undeveloped land provides a
link to that rural location and
therefore to develop the site would be
harmful and I think that's our
fundamental difference
there thank you for that um so we can uh
move on now um to the ward member if if
we may please thank you councelor
Ron thank you very much
chairman um you will have read the
reasons I have called this inter
committee and I and by those an
application as you know was submitted
and approved by buckel Parish Council
then the subsequent revised application
was then rejected by a new Parish
Council therefore it seemed appropriate
that both sides had a chance to put
their views to the committee I see this
an excellent example of a local family
connected to a long and well established
recognized
business as I said in my calling in form
I feel this would be an example of how
mids suffer could support the build of
an off-grid home with electric vehicles
solar panels battery storage much of
which can be expanded upon and has been
by the architect would this not show how
the council's commitment to climate
energy reduction climate energy
reduction and reduction in carbon
emissions
the design is to resemble a suff barn
rather than a modern domestic
building the
design also is although it is a large
site the property will be in the center
so will not be in the proximity of
nearby
dwellings I am pleased to see the
proposal for the sight enhancement is to
include only native species and intr
produce more wildflower seeds and Owl
boxes there are no objections from
highways and access will be by that
existing on sustainability mids gave
permission for five I think new
buildings on land to the edge of the
village so I am surprised to see in
paragraph 3.5 the statement buckel being
classified as a hamlet then small only
small scale infill growth will be
considered there are no facilities apart
from the pub open sometimes and a very
limited bus
service paragraph 7.2 States no harm is
identified for neighboring
properties and policy h16 seeks to
protect existing amenity and residential
areas therefore the sole reason for for
refusing the application lies only with
those on Heritage which is obviously a
difference of opinion and you will now
have heard from Dr hickey from historic
England those differences between that
and the council's Heritage
officer I fully understand the
objections made by residents who are
naturally concerned at the loss of a
piece of land which has been ConEd Ed an
important open space therefore chairman
this is the reason I've asked for this
to go to committee because I really feel
that it's an opportunity for the council
to look at this in detail and consider
um it's cons its um its merits in full
thank you very
much thank you councelor uton um before
I just go to questions for your goodself
I think Mr isbel might uh comment on the
foundation please Mr
isbel yeah thank you chairman yes
councelor Stringer mentioned the
foundations being uh being a query he
had for the agent and I've just been
reviewing the applicant's uh supporting
statement with the application there is
mention of the thermal Mass but I can't
see direct reference to the foundation's
question so at the moment I don't have
anything that I can confirm actually
embodies that within uh the nature of
the application itself so I'm a little
bit curious about uh uh that as a piece
of evidence and we wouldn't usually to
see that within a planning application
it would be a slightly unusual thing but
obviously it's relevant if it is there
but at the moment I don't have a direct
piece of information on the application
supporting statement under materials
which describes it thank you
chairman thank you for that um we now
move to questions for the ward member
councelor
Casten no questions thank you
chair councelor
gold uh just to clarify a a point I I
thought I heard cast Austin referred to
Dr hickey as coming from um historic
England but I thought I heard him
earlier say he was formerly employed by
historic England just be grateful for
clarification on that
[Music]
point oh yes that is
correct thank you for that any further
questions councelor
G no no that's it thank thank you very
much chair thank you councelor
Humphries no thank you madam
chair thank you councelor
melon uh yes chair um I just wanted to
ask uh councelor uton
um the this um application site is
clearly outside the sort of settlement
boundary of of bucksaw um and I wonder
how that sort of consideration came in
with with the sort of Parish Council and
the sort of various views there
yes there were
um several views obviously you'll see
from your reports obviously some felt it
was appropriate and there were mixed
feelings
basically any further question councelor
Melon No that's all thanks thank you um
counselor Stringer questions for for no
no no further questions thank you
counselor councelor War boys no further
questions and I don't have any questions
at this point thank you I now open up
the item for debate and we will go
around in an alphabetical order um
members are aware um to put a proposal
forward that they can
um uh do so in the window Paine but not
until the last person has had the
opportunity to speak on the first time
round uh so first of all councelor
Casten uh can I have your comments on
the application
please thank you very much
chair um okay so this location is
outside the development boundary um it
has
sustainab sustainability issues the
question is is this an exemption to the
rule of these sustainability issues we
have the applicants have already showed
that they have the intention and
resources to carry on with the
sustainability of the site I'm impressed
by the design with um with increased
biodiversity um within that from the
grass field um they the applicants have
a deep connection with this with the
village and um they're um likely to be
involved if not working in this ground
care business right next door the um
impact on the listed and surrounding
list of buildings and surrounding area
is not quite so important to me cu the
um North Side covered by the pond is um
quite a thick covering of hedge um the
real impact I can see is on the old
lawn's cottage which is um purely a view
because the um the the padic remains
right next door it just comes into that
view which is unfortunate but not
necessarily something that we need to be
considering here um it's um it doesn't
escape me that the pictures through the
Hedge have been taken in the winter time
which um is kind kind of um usually um a
bit of a trick to make something seem
more obvious than it is it's probably a
complete accident or when the last
applications came in and when they
needed to take them but there'll be a
lot more um coverage in the spring um so
and there's good screen in place with it
so I I think to me it is Up For Debate
how much of an impact this has on the um
listed buildings The Village um coming
into the um development boundary um
outside of it sorry and um the
sustainability so I'll listen very
keenly to the debate thank you
chair thank you councelor kaston
councelor gold
thank thank you uh chair yeah like
councilor cast I'm be uh interested to
listen to the debate uh as it develops
um I I note the in terms of the Heritage
impact uh but uh I'm inclined to I I
note that in in view of the in the light
of the debate that has been had
the our Our Heritage uh Team have have
not uh qualified or amended their their
advice and therefore I'm happy to uh to
to take that advice so it does come down
to me for uh the difference between the
obvious and commendable uh merits of The
Proposal in terms of its uh
environmental uh lack of environmental
impact uh and interesting aspects of of
design and indeed as councelor custen
has said the connection between um the
site owner uh the and the family
business and the locality uh is is an
important matter but for me it comes
down to fact we've got a single uh
dwelling um uh the benefits of which are
going to be limited placed against uh
the um the Heritage impact so uh I
should be interested to hear how the
debate um develops thank you
[Music]
chair thank you councelor g um I'll
leave any comments to the last as chair
as I normally do so councelor Humphrey's
please thank you madam chair um yeah on
first view this is this application
appears great it's a fantastic design
and I commend the guys that have
actually designed this I think it's
wonderful um however I'll come back to
some some negative size to it at the
moment but it is wonderful it looks
fantastic and and acknowledge the
attempt at the carbon offsetting by the
off-grid um technology it's it's amazing
fantastic but I welome back to it um so
that's on first look but on examination
there's many issues with it particularly
concerning the um the planned rural
location and it's the rural location
that I'll keep coming back to because I
think that's the important Point
especially when it comes to
nppf it's been well covered as well by
the officers uh in the presentation also
in the papers and the point here is to
is to understand the fact that although
this looks like a suff bar in design and
again credits the guys that designed it
the truth is that this is a a large
dwelling in a rural location so don't
forget that fact that's the point this
is a large dwelling irrespective of the
camouflage and all the great technology
it is a dwelling in the countryside of
quite a large dwelling um it's also
worth remembering I think um that the
previous application has been refused
and is currently appeal in fact it's the
second refusal uh this application apart
from some screening and the fact that
the roof height has been reduced by half
a meter so let's put that in real terms
18 in not great great amounts just the
length of your elbow really to your hand
um that's the only difference unless
someone wants to come back and tell me
these differences that I can't find or
haven't been explained by the officers
so there's very little difference to
this application to the one that is
currently at appeal due to refusal by
previous committee so that's important
to remember um and I'll come back to
that shortly so the level of harm on
this application also stands out is
considered be medium level of less than
substantial harm and that's regarded as
high bar and in my experience it's not
very common to be honest with to have
this High uh bar of potential
harm um I believe this and also the
recent court cases referred to in the
papers have wait and certainly outweigh
any benefits that are brought by the
off-grid um technology and design
statement um yeah it's it's a bit of an
issue me for me this one
um when we go to the ward members
comments about the Buel Parish Council
uh the books or Parish Council have
objected so let's make that quite clear
the previous one didn't but the one that
actually matters the one that's in place
right now has actually objected to this
application and that's the important
point on that um if we look at uh some
other things um we look at the well
let's go to the mppf shall we so let's
go to section 79 which I believe and I'm
just going to read it so I don't make a
mistake it's on page 22 of the mppf and
it talks about um rural housing because
this is a house not a barn um planning
policies and decisions should avoid the
development of isolated homes in the
countryside and if I'm not correct
please tell me but I believe that this
is an isolated house in the countryside
um unless one or more of the following
circumstances apply a there's an
essential need for the rural worker
including those taking majority control
of farm business to live permanently at
or near their place of work the
countryside well it's not an essential
need because this isn't Farm it's it's a
groundworks uh develop um uh business
the development would represent the
optimal viable use of Heritage access
well it doesn't the development would
reuse redundant or disused buildings it
doesn't the development would involve
the subdivision of an existing resident
it doesn't and uh paragraph B which is
the important one the design is of
exceptional quality in that it is truly
outstanding or Innovative reflecting the
highest standards in architecture and
would help raise standards of design
more generally in rural areas and would
significantly enhance this immediate
setting and be sent itive to the
defining characteristics of the local
area now you can take one of those
elements and say well this is
outstanding and it is innovative but on
one on page 139 uh 129 I believe it is
the officers disagree and they don't
find this to be um totally Innovative or
or outstanding although it is good um
and the second part of it it doesn't
enhance the imedia setting and it's not
sensitive to defining characteristics of
local area and that's been covered
clearly by the Heritage offices and all
the points
within the application itself so it
fails on the number of factors uh
particularly the mppf so Heritage side
alone don't forget this is a large
dwelling in the countryside and because
of that it has to meet certain
requirements and I don't think it does I
think it fails in quite a few ways um
the fact that the people need to they
can walk to work um well that's great
until they sell a house then what
happens and there's no s no move but
they they could sell the property um so
that that's a little bit of a herring
dis suppose in some respects um the key
pit with me though is that there's been
no actual massive change from the
refusal that set before the other
committee that's currently at appeal
apart from that Ridge height reduction
of 18 in um and it goes against the mppf
in many ways so Heritage aside uh the
mppf plays A Part here and that's that's
my thoughts so
far thank you for that counselor um I
will leave comments to my for myself as
I've said so we're on to councelor melon
if you would
please thank you chair um yes very
interesting to hear those points from um
my fellow counselors um yes I mean
clearly the points here
are the location of this development
it's it's in not not necessarily open
Countryside but it's in a in a a field
it's not um uh sort of infield or
anything like that um and it's outside
the settlement
boundary um the issues around
sustainability obviously they've put a
lot of work
into um the design of the building and
how it works um and I'm my limited
knowledge of of solar panels and and do
other sort of functions would I think it
probably will work there there's the you
know the cars to charge there's the the
functions of the house to run and then
the excess electricity to go into the uh
storage to be used at other times um so
in terms of the design of the house
there's sort of two elements to that
there's the
appearance um which you know is made to
look like a barn so that it doesn't look
obtrusive so that that then leads it to
not being an Innovative design in terms
of appearance I think the Innovation is
in the function of the
building the the way in which it's it's
it's off grid I mean that is that is
fairly rare really we do see houses um
coming up and applications coming up
where people have solar panels and we
have these other different bits of Green
Technology but having them all together
in one place and off- grid that is um
really quite
unusual so for me I think the
the the application hinges on this idea
about the Heritage setting and the kind
of difference between uh what the the
Heritage consultant has said that it
doesn't have you know substantial harm
or effect on the setting of these other
Heritage assets and then our own
officers view which is which is quite
contradictory to that so it seems to me
that is the the kind of really critical
point of the debate uh and I'm looking
forward to hearing what others have to
say thank you for that councelor melon
um I think um I will just bring in um
Philip Isbell on just one point that has
been raised um Mr Isbell could you just
come in on the point um that you wish to
assist us
on thank you chairman yes councelor
hum's um talked about the question of
isolated um the question of of whether
or not this was an isolated dwelling
under paragraph
79 um and uh just to clarify I mean
isolated uh is is a word that appeared
in the previous version of the nppf um
and indeed uh has been litigated I think
our colleagues in brry District Council
came on the receiving end of that uh and
uh I think it's uh it's probably fair to
say that to be isolated you would have
to be very very uh remote from other
dwellings and I would be cautious to
consider this an isolated site and I
would also in in saying that draw
attention to uh one of the appeals which
is referenced by the Heritage officer
here just for uh just had a
clarification relating to the uh group
of buildings opposite this site
isolation uh there was uh not considered
to be a problem uh or bit I think we
could say that uh in a in a common
common uh common a garden man on the
clap of ominous parliaments you would
probably consider this to be uh quite a
part or remote uh I think I would be
quite careful of using the uh the term
isolated to describe this under
paragraph 79 uh it is uh it is something
that has been quite well litigated and I
I I think it's not something I could
personally recommend to committee thank
you
chairman noted thank
you thank you help all was gratefully
received um councelor Stringer um would
you like to tell us your thoughts on the
application
please uh yes I will um in many ways I I
really really like the design it's it's
a sort of barn pasti uh if you want to
use that where that's word but don't
mean to be drry uh yeah I quite like the
sort of modern approach to that however
councelor Stringer can I interrupt can
you speak more into the microphone you
seem very faint okay sorry is is that
any better is that any better not a lot
but never mind okay right okay if I can
find out where it is I'll talk into it
right okay I don't know where it is on
this thing okay uh right is that any
better
no we just keep going just it was a
little better yeah okay thank you um
yeah the the the issue about the grid
thing is is I get what's being said but
I still the numbers don't quite Stack Up
in terms of you only have a certain
amount of power being stored here and
once it's gone it is gone uh and you
know you've got 40 odd kilowatt hours of
storage and a car will hold 30 that
doesn't leave a lot for the house but
anyway getting back to the actual
development itself it isn't actually
that Innovative what's been done uh the
technology is being used in houses all
the time I'm sitting in one I'm looking
at one being built 50 yards away from me
and there are three others sitting
behind me you know it is not that
Innovative so if we strip that away uh
and start looking at actually what the
development is being asked for here the
development is in in my view huge it it
equates to almost five normal domestic
houses worth so actually if you were to
sub we're not subdividing if you were to
subdivide it we're actually looking at a
huge Terrace of houses here basically of
domestic use in the middle of what is a
a lovely Meadow that has a foot paath
running along one side of it with open
views over it and a cluster of listed
structures all the way around it so I
think that immediately in my mind sets a
bit of caution and you need to really
justify why you need
to bring domestic curtilage into this
very very rural location I also am
slightly mindful of the Wild there
there's there's a thing about saying it
will enhance Wildlife because we're
putting boxes up well actually this
field is a perfect field for barnells to
actually hunt on so if you stick a house
in it you you you lessen the amount of
land that the barnells have to hunt on
so on my mind I think this is I I love
the Innovative approach I like what
they're doing in terms of pulling the uh
technology together that should be
happening in every house anyway frankly
uh so I I don't think the Innovation is
is enough to just by such a large amount
of built form and what I asked about the
foundations is they massing of concrete
concrete is an incredibly unsustainable
material in terms of its emissions it
has huge emissions in its production so
the larger the development the larger
the emissions in construction the less
sustainable the whole thing becomes so
for me the balance is tilted in favor of
me actually thinking this should be
rejected and not
approved
thank you for your comments there Andrew
Stringer councelor Stringer I think what
you must have been doing is waving your
papers around and walking away from the
microphone um but you did sound faint at
times but I thank you I got everything I
wrote everything down and thank you for
your comments um councelor War
boys yeah I think I must refer here to
what was previously been said I think uh
I agree with what councelor Miller said
in in terms of uh design that this this
very large house is is innovated in
terms of function I'm not that convinced
it's Innovative or outstanding in terms
of architectural
Merit um I think council is summed up a
lot of the negative aspects of this
developing and I just refer to what the
current bucko Parish Council say very
succinctly the site is currently
undeveloped and sits within an historic
part of the village with many listed
buildings reinforcing the rural nature
in which they stand I think our heritage
officers have developed that
argument um on page
153 C officer Chenery does refer to the
the
mapping of um the
settings uh but she does qualify these
settings and and does I think make a
very sound argument that they shouldn't
be considered definitive of the actual
setting of the historic
buildings
and there has been um a high bar set by
the arage offices in terms of the impact
of this uh development it is an isolated
house I think it it will result in a
very refined domesticated setting and I
think it will be contrary to and
damaging to
the setting of the listed
buildings thank you for that counselor
um and now we've got to the point where
I um could say something um I will I've
listened to everybody's points of
view um and I agree with many of them um
there's some good um and um the main
concerns I've got are the heritage
issues and it is huge I think councelor
Stringer summed it up when he described
the number of um smaller houses that
could go in
it um I worry that it came to committee
when there's already one running at
appeal and it may well have helped us
all had we had the result of that appeal
but I'm
uncomfortable with this
application and I would uh be looking uh
to support the planning
officer so that's my view on it so we
can move on to a second time um or if
anybody has a proposal to make I'm quite
happy hang on councelor humph has
offered to make a proposal would you
like to verbally tell us that proposal
please mam chair yes thank you um before
we start though please ignore or redact
my word isolated from the comments the
comments still understand concurs with
counselor Stringer fully actually that
this is a huge development in a
Countryside location and and for all the
points he raised um because there is no
massive change to the original um
application apart from the reduction of
half a meter in height from The Ridge
and the fact that this is still at
appeal um and having listened to the
debate uh I would like to propose um
that we refuse this application for all
the previous um recommend uh for all the
comments that are actually listed within
the papers under the recommendation um
and again because this is appeal uh as
you say I think it' have been really
useful if we had have waited until the
end of the appeal before bringing this
back to committee but we are where we
are so we can't change the historic
location we can't change anything really
it's a large dwelling in a historic uh
area um and I think all the comments and
all the points that have been raised in
the recommendation which refusal are
valid um and therefore I'd like to move
for for
refusal thank you for that councelor um
I will ask for a second and then I will
go round again to everybody to uh to
allow them to speak to the motion so do
I have a seconder for councelor
Humphrey's
proposal chairman could I just interrupt
uh no not now councelor could you just
clar if that councelor Matson is not a
member of the
committee he's he's not being asked to
say anything so could could we just
carry on
with thank you if I use the word ma it
was a it was a slip of the tongue did I
use the word mat I beg your pardon
anyway um hang on we've got councelor
warboys has seconded the U motion oh he
just as councilor M was part of the
discussion on the
original no councelor oton I don't think
we need any further input on this
councelor mat will not be taking any
part of this at all I can assure you I
quite
agree so Madam chair I agree with you
totally may I just butt in here and if I
may and say i' I've noticed councelor
Norris appears to be back with us which
is very good to see but I I am sure he
he will not be voting on this item I
don't Mr Carmichael are you seeing as
well that he's there with
us
yeah
thank thank you for that so um we've now
got a seconder which is councelor war
boys um I think at this point we will go
round again in order to ask if people
wish to speak to the motion or pass any
further comments and then um I will ask
um the um planning officer to read out
the recommendation in full and then we
will go to a vote so any further
comments councelor
Casten thank you very much chair I I've
been listening to the debate on the um
on the size and I think yes it is a very
big house um we do need to build very
big houses every so often and um when we
do build them I'd like them to be of
this standard to um and um off grid if
you like I'm still in favor of this um
development at the moment I can
understand why counselors are thinking
mind minded to refuse at this stage
because there are issues with it but um
at the moment I'm
still for approving this thank you very
much yes that's fine councelor cast and
we'll ask you on the vote when we go
forward but thank you for your input
councelor ghoul do you have any further
comments to make uh no I'm listening to
the debate with interest and find my uh
s in agreement with uh with with the
proposal and uh the reasons for that
thank you
thank you councelor councelor humph
obviously you um proposed it do you want
to make any further comments at all
you're allowed a second or third go as
it were M chair I stand by The Proposal
like said just agree Council C there's
lot lots of good things about this but
it is where it is and that's the problem
and uh and it's already been refused
there are no changes so I stand by The
Proposal thank you councelor Maron would
you like to make a further comment or
are you happy with what's been gone on
uh yeah thank you chair no
um yes I mean I've heard the debate and
and um I accept that there is some very
good things about the this uh this
application um but there's some some
significant problems with it as well um
one one of the aspects of
sustainability um is the size of a
building uh there's no getting away from
it uh if you if we want to live more
sustainably um we we we probably need to
be uh habiting smaller spaces um and and
this clearly isn't a small space I'm not
entirely sure I was trying to look in
the application to see how many people
would be living there um if it's an
extended family or whatever but um it is
a a big size and that is sort of
weighing fairly heavily on my
mind thank you for that c councelor
Stringer yeah thank thank you chair uh
I've got nothing really more to add and
I think trying to be helpful to the
applicant I think it is that mass and
size that we are having most difficulty
with I think and the repercussions of
that uh the sustainability issues built
into it I think we all applaud and would
welcome I just think it is the sheer
scale of this thing that is that is you
know pushing it over the edge into terms
of
sustainability thank you for that
councilor War
boys any further comments
I'm happy to second the motion uh I I I
think it is good to see ambitious
designs coming forward with regards to
Energy Efficiency but I don't regard
that as offsetting the idea of this very
large house in the middle of open an
open setting and damaging the listed
buildings the historical
context thank you for that um and I have
no further comments to make on what I'd
already made so can I ask Robert
carmichel to conduct a vote please thank
you thank you chair so this is the vote
for the actually we need to have the um
hang on I need the officer to read the
motion out for us in full because not
everybody has the sight of it so um uh
Sean bondre would you like to just read
the recommendation as per page 133
please
thank you chairman the recommendation of
refusal um is firstly that the site's
character as an undeveloped field is
fundamental to its contribution to the
setting of many of the nearby listed
buildings and the rural context in which
they
stand the proposed dwelling would
significantly detract from the Open
Country Side character of the area the
rural setting of The Village and the
rural setting of the nearby designated
Heritage assets the latter being harmful
to the significance of the designated
Heritage
assets these adverse impacts
constituting significant environmental
harm would significantly and
demonstrably outweigh the scheme's
modest economic social and environmental
benefits and would not deliver
sustainable development contrary to
policy fc1 and fc1 D one of the core
strategy Focus review
2012 the national planning policy
framework
2019 and section
661 of the planning listed building and
conservation areas act
1990 as well as policy hb1 of the mids
local Plan
1998 and policy CS5 of the core strategy
2008 and the second reason is that the
site area exceeds 0.5 hectares and as
such affordable housing requirements are
triggered on this basis the proposed
development fails to secure affordable
housing provision on site or a
contribution for provision elsewhere and
is cont to the nppf and altered local
Plan 1998 policy
H4 thank
you so uh Robert would you now like to
ask for people and it needs to be clear
it's always very difficult when you're
recommending but it's a recommendation
for refusal so could you go around the
members please thank you chair again I
will ask as a roll call vote of for
against or
abstain so councelor James
caraston against the
proposal councelor Peter
gold for the
proposal councelor Kathy Guthrie
for the proposal of
refusal Council Barry
Humphries for the proposal for refusal
councel Andrew
melon for the
proposal councel oh sorry councelor
Stringer
for and councelor Roland War
boys for the
proposal
thank you Chair by six votes to one the
motion is
carried yeah I chairman I've counted
also and I endorsed that thank you Mr
Carmichael thank you for both of that um
I think now if we could have um a
10-minute Comfort break or would it be
better for five um what do you think
councelor um um um Robert
Carmichael uh if we say to come back at
um 5 past 12 um go for that and I I'll
put something on the screen as well
chair and mutal
participants and and I'd be happy that
you didn't disconnect us just mute us
would be fine thank you very much indeed
and thank you for everyone thank
you
[Music]
for
Cel
Stringer and councilor war councelor war
boys present and the ward member
councelor
mat present thank you chair we are all
here excellent um do we need to advise
the members of the public when we go
live streaming or should we should we
just start off that all members of the
committee are present and start I was
going to say chair we are live streaming
now so and there are no public speakers
for this item so I would suggest we get
underway as
such indeed so thank you very much for
rejoining um and we now come to the um
application dc1
18491 land adjacent to buckel Lodge
buckel Road great finnur and I'll now
ask the case officer Katherine hail to
introduce the application to the
committee thank you very much indeed
Katherine thank you chair can you see my
screen I presume the Powerpoints up yep
that's fine good so this application is
for 28 dwellings um including nine
affordable it's a full
application in obiously great
fbra so great fbra is designated as a
primary Village in the adopted course
strategy and this slide shows you see
the site location in in context with the
surrounding
area this is an aerial view to put into
context with surrounding adjacent
dwellings and as you'll see in the next
coming slides this here is buckel Lodge
which is a listed
building so the constraints map listed
building here to the west of the site
and another grade two listed building to
the southeast of the site and this shows
that it's currently outside the existing
settlement boundary so this brown line
that goes around is where the settlement
boundary is for great F at present
time so going to the site and bux or
Lodge being the grade two listed
building this is I'll see the lodge here
and this is the entire site with the
existing chestnut
tree so just to put some context um into
your CV bent listed
building you can see the photo and this
is here in the right hand corner just
shows where roughly the photo's been
taken from so this is the listed
building in the distance
here the listed building is just out of
shot here in this slide these are the
out buildings towards the
back this is as you can see well screen
so the listed building is actually here
you can just see the chimney stack and
that's the front gate to towards it and
therefore the development site is behind
this hedro and these trees
here this is another photo of the
front and then this is the site so just
here in the distance you can see um part
of boxal
Lodge this is obviously more site from
the very Northern Edge at the
moment
just so see another Vantage Point again
it's depicted down here so you get a
rough idea where the photo was taken
from and this shows OB see how the
slight the site does slope so
slightly and here is just a stitched
obviously photos of the the whole site
again very very faintly in the distance
here is part of the the buildings in the
background so um The Proposal originally
came in for preap um and a revised SCH
initial scheme had um OB see Heritage
implications in terms of Heritage made
an assessment that the proposal that was
initially submitted would cause um a
fair amount of harm to the setting of
the list of building so this is how the
initial submission looked and you can
see here that the site um in terms of
residential dwellings was situated quite
close to the listed building the scheme
has undergone several amendments in
order to try and mitigate um any harm
that it may have on the listed building
and therefore the residential
development for the scheme has been
pushed back further to the Easter site
um and it provides for separation
distances of 64 at a minimum
point so as just mentioned the um
heritage team did demonstrate that there
would be harm to the proposal the
Heritage team have said that there will
be a medium level of less than
substantial harm to buckel
Lodge um the mppf at paragraph 196 says
that obviously um any harm Which is less
than substantial whether it's obviously
low medium or high within that category
should um have LLY any public benefits
should therefore outweigh the
harm so in this case the proposed scheme
the public benefits are obviously as as
follows um in that there increases a
provision of housing numbers which will
help the council maintain our current
5-year housing land Supply sustain our
delivery rate it increases a choice and
types of homes within the village there
are 35% affordable which is nine in this
instance
um employment opportunities as well as
res future occupiers and residents would
also use the existing facilities within
the village as well as within the wider
rural community it also provides open
space and various other green
features in terms of a proposal scheme
with regards to the sustainability and
location in the village as mentioned
earlier at the moment the site lies
outside of the adopted settlement
boundary but it is adjacent to it on
obviously all its
edges it was part of the Sheila s um
that were brought forward when preparing
the emerging joint draft joint local
plan and as a result in the emerging
draft joint local plan the settlement
boundary has been altered to include
include the site you can see here where
it's flashing it encompasses the entire
site and goes back into the existing
Village it's noted that um great finra
is where it's a primary Village the
local shop has closed and there aren't
potentially aren't any bus services um
however it is 2 and a half miles to Stow
Market um it's it's considered to be a
sustainable location on the basis of it
great finb does have the pub um and it
does have primary school and whilst
there aren't um there isn't a shop it is
within a short commute to um OB Stone
Market a large town which provides these
facilities and in fact recently a
planning inspector found that um a site
actually in buckel further away from
this scheme so about a month mile
further away from the Stow Market was
considered to be sustainable and well
located um in terms of the access and
services and Facilities to Stow market
and that yes they would need to use
private Motorcar however the the
distance involved would be very
short so this was the initial
scheme um which was initially for 32
houses
and the amended scheme is as follows
we've reduced the houses down to
28 and as you can see there there are um
OB see a larger open space on the
western edge and um we've tried to
incorporate a more a less Suburban more
rural edges where possible on this
one in terms of the topography as you
have um seen from a photographs the site
does slide um slope ever so slightly
obviously towards West so it's higher on
the eastern
boundary and this is obviously just a
slide to show where the residential
units um are proposed in relation to the
topography so the site um the scheme
proposed has Al say a number of
advantages there we've made sure that
there are VAs on all um angles from
outside of the site and that as you'll
see from latest slides the detailing of
the properties are to a good design that
there are no flank
walls um and there's continuous Frontage
where
necessary here obviously with a large
amount of open space we've ensured that
residential dwellings are fronting it
and overlooking it that provides a sense
of security and the open space is
surveilled at all
times again open space to the east is
also surveilled at all times with the
properties overlooking
it the same there's a foot link through
the north of the site where the existing
gate was from the first photos and again
this foot foot paath is um monitored and
surveilled by the proposed
dwellings here the Red Arrows just show
where they dual
elevations um to obviously again create
a a less urbanized feel um provide
overlooking for open space and the gray
obviously gray element just shows where
we've removed all the development to
push it further to the east to provide
the setting for the Buel
Lodge besides well connected both within
RC you know itself as well as um the
adjacent foot paath um and way
into great fbra so this is the main
access road is down along the Eastern
site you've got the foot link to the
north and it joins the existing foot
paaths along here there are foot paaths
around the green
spaces um so these are proposed
elevation
um we tried to secure a good design on
these um so we've got a bungalow here
which is Affordable and these
elevations um will form part of what
we're calling OB The Village Pond
Frontage but to put that into context
those elevations are
here
so this main slide this main elevation
front here would be those ones and then
this down
here
encapsulates these properties and OB see
this plots it's taken from The Wider
vantage
point this is just a representative
floor plan for for those
plots um and here you can see obviously
we've provided one Bungalow um which is
two
beds we've also got um some flat in the
scheme which it has been pointed out at
the moment then below the national
defined space standards however it's
been agreed with the agent that we can
adjust this
wall we can adjust this wall so that
they'll effectively make sure that they
comply with the the space standards um
this would obviously should members be
minded to approve this would be secured
by way of
condition
so again this is just for frontages
along the estate
road so here you can see obviously we
tried to get um detailed design with
arches above
Windows um and bay windows and um Door
and Window sorry and various other
architectural designs and rather than
fences they're joined and linked by by
brick
walls again just toly put it into
context that's this this would be the
elevation
here this is um as we see you emerge
into the site these are in the style of
typical agricultural key worker
dwellings in terms of their
style um to try and reflect on OB see
the local characteristics of Great
fimber and The Wider rural
area and again into context these are
the elevations involved so along here as
you enter into the
site these are the proposed flats for
for the scheme um four
flats and this is where they are in in
the scheme so there these will be all
affordable um the reason the affordable
homes aren't pepper potted obviously
around with site and main one main area
are because um you know it's under 15
and when it's under 15 we we don't need
to Pepper pop them around the site this
is where another two are as
well this just shows the the design of
the um the
flats so we've tried to see add um more
architectural features um taken from
around great
fimber also the um this is a front and
will secure by condition um of brick
wall which would um surround the flats
and provide um screening for the
proposed parking spaces but this just
gives you a feel of what it would look
like and then um obviously Flats can
sound quite alarming particularly in a
village this is just um a slide which
shows the ridge height
comparisons so at the moment a lot of
the properties have non . 6 or 9.7 Ridge
Heights and the flats proposed at the
maximum Ridge height would be 9.6
M and and one end would obviously be
slightly lower at
8.7 so they wouldn't sit any higher than
the the proposed
dwellings these are the proposed
properties for the new green Frontage
which is to the West um of the site
again obviously the top one is a zoomed
out version you can see the detail more
clearly here um I'm G for a range of
features again the brick wall rather
than ra than
fences and this is obviously showing
where where these elevations would be in
the
scheme so these are the properties um in
terms of the design you've got see um
oral
windows um Soldier courses window
reveals glazing units all of which can
be secured by condition and for
materials will be against skilled by
condition and include traditional
vernacular
palette um in terms of parking this is
just to show we see where the parking is
in in terms of the residential units and
that we've ensure there's adequate
parking per residential unit on the
scheme
and again down here with visitor parking
also
provided this slide shows the new access
road which is OB off high road um on the
east of the site and that the visibility
displays can be achieved and are within
the site um site boundary and site
ownership a small amount of vegetation
will need to be removed which um I'll
sort of show you later on in the slides
um whether where possible this will then
be replanted further into the site um so
it won't be completely lost it'll just
be
relocated and this is to put the scheme
obviously into local context so the
access would be down here um and then
obiously you've got um the
chestnuts which are fairly
um standard houses
and then also further to the north
you've got more traditional um
properties and buildings which we've
tried to OB use to influence the um
design for the elevations that we've put
forward for this scheme including the
flat you can see that there some
detailed elements that have been carried
over again this is just more context of
surrounding development so as you can
see in the left this is two towards the
sort of Northwestern edge of
site and again the these properties are
roughly opposite the site where the
access would be on the road um in terms
of the Hedge R and trees that would be
potentially lost it would start further
down but it would be no further than
around here um in terms of what would be
removed which as you can see from this
photo a lot of it is fairly dead
anyway although that you know there is
at the
moment in terms of landscaping the
existing chestnut tree which is down
here we' sought to
retain and obviously various tree
protection measures will be um
conditioned to make sure that the
development doesn't affect our
tree this slide shows the soft
Landscaping plan for for the S so you
can see that it's it's very green um
we've obviously got plenty of open space
to the West open space Also to to the
east um rather than having frontages
right onto onto the road it's softened
with the existing hedro further planting
as well as then
Gardens um and various trees and green
spaces amongst the the scheme as
proposed
so this just shows the the existing
submission again to to reinforce that it
was originally much further out um
losing a lot of open space we insisted
that it was all pushed back um the the
road that ran around the entire western
edge of a site has largely been removed
there is a small Shar drive here but
that is obviously Shar drive and um then
a foot path which we see go straight
into the the green open space and AAS
table here as well to soften the the
feel of the proposed development
site so that's the end of the
presentation so the recommendation is to
Grant um subject to see section 106 and
also
conditions
thank you that Katherine that was a very
very useful walk around the site um and
uh very helpful
presentation um I'll now go to um the
members and ask them if they have
questions for you so first of all can I
come to councelor cine please any
questions for Katherine thank you very
much chair just um from this um layout
is there any boundary from the flats
right down in that bottom left hand
corner onto the open space um I can't I
can't quite see from the picture is
there can you just access that or or do
you have to walk around
anywhere slide seven I'm looking at
which is quite
useful don't forget our numbers will be
different to
theirs
hello sorry are you waiting for me to um
oh no sorry I was muted um okay yes so
the the existing fats will have a brick
wall around the front and I believe they
will be screened but I imagine a walkway
is into the open space which I think is
depicted on a another slide if you just
let me
flip through
them I believe this is this might be the
front I don't have it but no there will
be um access to the open space from the
flat that answers your question yes
thank you very much that's great thanks
thank you
chair thank you counselor Casten just
before I move on can I just remind
members that we do have um additional
table papers with suggested additional
com conditions to the committee report
um and just to make sure that
everybody's got those which include
archaeological conditions highways
conditions finished floor level details
relevant to the adjoining sites
including section drawings to be
submitted and approved prior to
commencement ecology mitigation as per
Place service recommendations and
Renewables to Encompass rainwater har
harvesting EV points on all plots just
to remind members of that as we go
through the questions to the officer
sorry to have interrupted so um
councelor Gould do you have any
questions for the
officer thank you chair um yeah my U
couple of um questions concerns I have
in relation to uh uh transport and
infrastructure can you um clarify what
is available in terms of bus service uh
locally so it was believ that up until I
think March this year there was a
limited bus service in operation um I
think is now ceased um as suff County
Council um review their transport
policies I believe that Hadley um
Community offer a Dial A Ride scheme
which serves great thra um so there is
that option to resident although there's
not a a designated set um and bus for
the site no no no scheduled service no
no no okay in terms of the uh a note
from the uh Parish council's comments
that there they're claiming no no
traffic survey was undertaken um I I I
wondered if that was the case and also
uh I'm wondering about the aggregated
impact of this development together with
the 24 houses previously
agreed the sites um OB see are taking on
their own Merit in terms of the
implications of traffic on the on the
highway um I imagine suffet County
Council and providing their response
would have had due regard to to the
other site um they don't have a any
concerns with the scheme in that regard
um in terms of the transport survey um
or traffic survey I'm I can't remember I
need to go back and and look at the all
the documents provided and and have a
look and answer shortly if that was
okay that's that's fine thank you very
much and I'm I'm right in understanding
that the uh local school is full and
that there are no um uh shop cropping
facilities within within the village
itself that's so yeah so the the local
shop um has closed however um the site
is deemed still sustainable in the terms
since that is the local pub um and the
site as I previously mentioned was a
previous scheme a planning inspectorate
deemed to be appropriate in terms of its
location to
other Villages for services and
Facilities um which is actually further
away than this site and therefore it's
been considered that the site is
sustainable under our local policy and
the mppf due to the close proximity of
Stow market and that admittedly
obviously future occupi will use their
car however there'll be for very short
and brief Journeys and it's highly
likely that these Journeys will then be
linked in the sense that you'd go to um
Stone market for for things such as the
the gym and Cinema which um potential
residents already do in great fimber
anyway okay thank you very
much thank you counselor we now go to
councelor humph
please M chair thank you I'm just like
to say really good use of slides
actually it's nice to see the
photographs and have an indication of
where they're taking from and that
panoramic view actually helped us a lot
in sort of working out the topography so
thank for that um couple of questions
the first one um the suffer preservation
comments within the papers talk about
the existing screening between the site
and Lodge can you confirm that the
adequate screening will be retained
rather than be removed to soften the
blur against the lodge that's the first
question and the second question is
regarding the bus routs bus route 461
that used to run to great fbra you're
right that finished in March but seacon
board report that actually um
alternative funding options being sorts
it might not have been stopped and um do
you have any Clarity on that as to
whether they found that funding and
whether they're going to bring back the
bus or not I know it might be too
difficult but I was just thought I'd
ask um I I don't know in terms of the
the bus Sumer funding it might be that
um Phil can chip in um he might know
more in terms of the screening we can
ensure that this is um maintained and
not removed um if it's in our ownership
um as part of or if it's in the
applicants ownership as part of a scheme
if it lies within um obviously the Buel
Lodge ownership if they were to it would
be out of our control so we can only
control what's in the site but the
screening along the western boundary
would remain um as it
is thank
you thank you councelor Humphries now
councelor melon any questions for the
officer
please uh yes chair I have a couple
um um well I had one about EV charging
points but it seems like uh we we're
going to be a to deal with that under
conditions um because there was nothing
particularly in the application about
provision of those um a couple of things
I wanted to ask about one is um the suff
preservation Society um submission talks
about harm to the uh tree there's a
chestnut tree on the site um and I
wonder how we can mitigate against that
harm um and the other thing is um
looking at the figures for the
affordables it claims that 9 out of 28
is
35% just having a quick go on a
calculator that comes to
32% um by my calculation and we'd have
to have 10 um affordable units to get to
35% can you just explain the discrepancy
there thank
you um I'm not sure how I can explain
the discrepancy um we originally had it
down as eight and then realized that 28
would be nine we do round down so that
may be maybe where the discrepancy is um
in terms of that one um with regards to
tree mitigation the chest tree will be
retained on site um and various tree
protection measures will be um
conditioned should obviously members
Grant okay thank
you thank you councelor melon um
councelor Norris do you have questions
for the officer
please uh thank you yes just one um this
is referred to as an amended application
on page 21 there is reference to another
application presumably the original
application dc18
00221 I've attempted to look this up on
the application search and comment but
in fact I can't find it on the system it
might have been useful to be able to
look at the original full original
application um to compare the changes on
this amended one does the officer have
any comment on that thank you actually I
can jump in on that one because that
really was under if if uh Katherine
doesn't mind that was on the um
pre-planning would I be correct on that
Katherine maybe you should read answer
yes so um that was it wasn't actually a
formal planning application that was our
pre-planning um pre-application advice
that we provided under that reference um
so we don't make pre application advice
public so that's why obviously searching
for that you can't find anything so they
were internal conversations which led
to
this um which was originally 32
dwellings and then subsequently revised
during the
process uh thank you for that I
understand and thank you for the
question councelor Norris I too had
queried that in our briefing so um it's
very good that people spot these things
um and I will just before I come to
councelor Stringer if you would please
just a bit of support here and I think
Mr isbel can just give us that little
bit of support
please uh thank you chairman yes so uh
the question uh councilor melon raised
regarding affordables and I'm just
scrolling through the pages in The
version I have of the background
papers and if I can get I think it's
page 84
is a comment that's page page 85 sorry
page 85 is a comment from Louis Barker
housing enabling uh officer and that's
that's our housing enabling team who
advis us on the content of affordable
housing uh and that says revised dation
28 dwellings uh 28 units should offer
nine affordable housing units equals 35
35% policy compliant position so I
imagine this is a rounding issue thank
you chairman there was one other thing
that Katherine didn't mention about
knowledge around buses and whether I
might add anything I don't know anymore
about the position with funding of buses
I'm afraid so uh I can't add to that
thank you
J thank you for that um reply chair
councelor melon here can uh well it's
debate rather than it's questioning
rather the debate well it's a
clarification I'm
seeking okay then well just looking at
the M Stringer councelor melon will just
ask for a clarification so just um
following back on um uh Mr isbell's um
comment so eight out of 28 homes would
be
28.57% nine out of 28 would be
32.1 10 would be
35.7 so however you round it N9 is
nowhere near
35 uh chairman if I may respond um yes
please do the the the advice we have and
the advice is is as as I say in the
background papers is that uh have
enabling team consider this to be policy
compliant and I think the advice there
is self-explanatory I haven't sat down
with the calculator I don't think it's
difficult maths um but that's the advice
we we have had from colleagues in our
housing enabling team chairman thank
you and councelor melon I do I do
understand your query but sometimes
there are um adjustments and I suppose
this has been just one of those but a
worthwhile point and we can use in the
debate as you choose
um thank you for that so counselor
Stringer you're very patient thank you
very much indeed um do you have
questions for the officer please yes I
do I can also offer an answer to
councelor melan uh it's rather like
Broadband speeds affordable housing is
up to 35% it rarely rarely goes over
that uh just to sort if that helps uh
number of questions uh I when bucka was
listed as a primary Village in the Cor
stry what services did it have at the
time it was given the primary Village
status that helped it gain that status
uh could I also ask about the affordable
housing given there's no local housing
need survey what informed the mix that
we asked
for uh also I want to know you've
compared to roof Heights but what we
what we want to know is the comparison
with the existing houses actually on the
other side of the road because it's very
difficult it's just a number uh so so
what would be really helpful to know
is how tall are the buildings on the
other side of the road compared with the
ones that you listed uh and also I want
a clarification on the visibility spays
I know highways are slightly notorious
for uh you know not giving us too much
detail but it would really be nice to
know because there are there are clear
guidelines as to what visibility you
should have and this access is on the
outside of a Bend which is always
difficult to gain visibility from
because you're looking as it were
backwards not forwards so I'd like some
clarification about that uh also sorry I
keep asking questions uh the you
mentioned an appeal in buckel that meant
that this site could be deemed as
sustainable was that site in Buckle a
major application and did it include
affordable housing that's all I've
got okay I think I've noted all of those
down but after I've attempted to answer
if I've missed any um just let me know
so in terms of the services in in
2008 when I see it was made a primary
Village um under the course strategy I
believed it had the local shop then um
obiously bus services although I can't
say whether the bus services were any
fre than what they have recently been um
I believe it still had the pub the
school and the Village Hall um so it's
it's obviously Lo the loss now is the
shop and the the bus um route although
that you know potentially might might
come
back um in terms of the the Heights and
the maximum Ridge Heights that slide um
perhaps was a bit misleading it was more
to show that the flats
um proposed weren't going to be um
ridiculously high or or out of character
um and go above the proposed dwellings
um in terms of obviously getting it um
rid Heights and floor levels in
comparison to the neighboring properties
that will be secured by condition and I
believe it was on the table papers um
that we would seek to get a finished
floor levels um um condition put on the
scheme one for the topography um to
assess how that works um but also the
The Wider Site Area and neighboring
dwellings um and
then the affordable housing was based
obviously on the housing strategy team
um assessing the housing data and and
going from from there um and I think
this scheme being revised once or twice
on on the basis of Heritage and also
then um strategic housing comments to
incorporate um their
requests thank you very much for
that um we now move on to councelor war
boys if you'd like a question for the
officer please uh no questions thank
you um thank you um
I do have a couple of questions actually
um when the Sheila um was explored and
everything what were the expected
numbers likely to be on this site which
seem to have been
allocated um I don't have that to hand
and I believe they were discounted in
terms of it being pro brought for um
forward as a a a designated site
allocation with a set prescribed numbers
instead the settlement boundary as
depicted um is shown to have moved to
incorporate the site and therefore imply
that um it is then in the settlement
boundary and has the potential for
development without limiting or stating
the the number of dwellings on that so
that's just so basically that slide was
to show that it was considered as a
allocated site deemed un you know
unsuitable um I'm not quite sure why but
instead has been put into the settlement
boundary to allow some form of
development um what that see is would
then be down to our consideration and
members of the committee and so
on thank you for that and I have another
question um I did ask this and I'm not
sure we got the answer to it from
briefing which was uh what are the size
of the garages so can cars fit in them
and the second part of that you said
there was was adequate parking but it's
all very well to say per the suffk
guide um are we sure what sort of
numbers are we talking about here but in
particular what is the size of the
garages
please um the size of the garages I
don't have the the information to hand
they'll meet obviously the standards and
conform with the conditions specified by
um highways which are on obviously set
out I think in the committee paper um in
terms of the the parking spaces this um
this will
be at least two spaces per a two bed
house and so on and um
adequate visitor spaces as well um they
can be conditioned and the the garages
have to meet the the standard size for
the cars otherwise highways would have
put in in a rejection um and
alternatively we could condition it
anyway
uh I think that's an important point
because I've been doing this long enough
and I remember some that we had up at
Stow Market you could get the car in but
you couldn't open your door so we need
we need to be quite careful on that
please um they're my questions and um we
have the ward member and does the ward
member have any questions of the
planning hang on a minute just a minute
of the planning officer before we start
um going through and um going through
with the debate and so on so questions
for the planning officer if you would
please cancel right yes I'm grateful to
some um some of the members asking some
of my questions already I didn't hear
the answer on the bux all appeal is how
many houses and did it have any
affordables in it that appeal decision
oh sorry that's um correct I missed that
question um no it was for one dwelling
um and O see therefore no affordables
and and no um potential public other
considerations oh that appeal oh right I
I know know which one we're talking
about now because it used to be my ward
of course um also
the
um sorry just where we going here yes
the questions
are um now there answers I'll come back
to those when I get my time um yeah I
think really the the other one is it's a
clarification regarding the the extent
to which the Hedge will be
removed um the um I my reading of the
what I've got here is slide seven
although I do I do have the old papers
not the new papers so my page numbering
is is uh wrong but slide seven is the
site layout and really looking at the
visibility playay um that's needed which
take which covers 2third of the site um
the Hedge isn't that
thick and I it seems to me that we will
actually lose a very great deal of the
Hedge
coun question please rather than
debating isue you know the reloc the
officer spoken about about not
completely lost but
relocated um so my question really is is
how much hedge is actually going to be
removed uh and my estimate is 2/3 of the
site front yeah we don't need your
estimate we just need the question is
how much is going to be
removed I haven't got a measurement of
the you know the exact meterage but the
removal of the Hedge obviously would
come up to roughly where this house is
here and as you can see
on this this slide now how far it will
go in order to maintain the visibility
spays and it will simply be relocated
slightly further back in order to
achieve it at the moment it runs all
along
here but I don't I don't have the
precise obviously um amount that is
going to be removed in terms of it's not
being measured to
hand do you have a further question
counselor I I think I think not um I'll
leave everything else for my
presentation thanks thank you excellent
thank you we'll listen to that with
interest um just a moment um I believe
Mr isbel was going to help us with
regard to the
appeal uh thank you chairman yeah I can
probably shed some light on that and the
garage internals I'm I'm checking with
colleagues but as I understand it they
do appear to be and the the the parking
standard as I recall it from the suff
design guide is not less than 3x6 M
internal I believe these may be 3.5 by7
I am checking that as as we go so uh
they should be at least the suff design
guide stand as it presently stands the
appeal uh not far removed from the
previous site we dealt with this morning
chairman uh there were two appeals on
that site and the second one concluded
that uh buxa was a sustainable
settlement uh made reference to both
great fimber and ratton as being um for
places with a greater variety of
services and employment uh and indeed
made reference to uh paragraph 7 8 of
the nppf which for those uh enthusiasts
of of that document as I know we we all
are uh talks about uh uh effectively uh
allowing for opportunities where groups
of smaller settlements uh uh work
together as a whole and uh development
in one Village May Support Services in
the village nearby now in that appeal
which was dismissed nonetheless the
inspector took the view that that was an
approach that applied to
bucksaw and I think I think to that
extent you can uh kind of take it that
uh it will be difficult to uh make too
much of a point around the uh connection
and grouping of sustainable uh of
settlements that work together but um
that was that's theal withd drawing upon
chairman thank you that was helpful um
and during our debate I'm sure that we
comment on the appeal inspector's
assessment of suffle I suppose thank you
um
so we now come to councelor mat if you
would so if you'd like to give us your
report on the the site before us thank
you very much thank you very much the
parish council submission I think I
would urge members to look carefully at
the many many points very well presented
by them uh there is there is a
fundamental
pair of problems with this firstly fbra
is no longer a sustainable
location um it we we didn't only have a
shop we also had a post office and we
had a bus service which was four times a
day in each Direction each six days a
week when when finra was made a primary
Village so I think you can see having
lost all those things um that's why it's
proposed to be a hinterland Village in
the forthcoming um draft
jlp the the other big problem is that
there is not a need we currently have
7,668 dwellings approved and that's in
January 2020 confirmed Supply figures
provided by planning policy to the jlp
working
group I know unfortunately there isn't
any response from planning policy on
this
application so those are the key
points so if I could then talk
particularly about the highway safety
issue Council string has mentioned this
this uh action of the
bend um there hasn't been any comment
and question thus far on the speed but
the the average speed in the Council
detail you will see average is 39 M an
hour as against the 30 mph limit and the
the maximum recorded is is basically off
the clock at 79 I think it was uh you've
seen this is actually very near the
school and the parish has correctly
pointed out that The Pedestrian access
from
the um from the site is is actually onto
a very awkward awkward location where
you've got you've got a difficulty in in
having visibility
in more than one of the three directions
that the traffic's coming to you at so
it's actually rather an awkward an
awkward point to have that um pedestrian
access point so that's the that's the
highway issues then the question of
we're often told about our policies
being out of date and so on and as I've
said really as a the primary Village is
it is hopelessly out of date the shop
went the post office went the bus
service has been reduced from four each
way a day to twice a week and now to
nothing at all and the pub is
unfortunately open only over the last
few years years has only been opened
intermittently it's had periods of two
total closure and periods of opening for
three days a week and and things like
that which again I think is commented in
more detail in the parish council's um
objections so we're going to find fbra
is just about making sufficient um
sufficient
Services because of the school to to
remain a hint land Village it's it's I
think it's on the it's on the lower end
of the services available to even make
it as a hinterland village now so it is
not a sustainable location in those
terms any longer now I'd like to mainly
then look at everything else in terms of
the three elements of sustainability
under the
mppf um I think we we always accept that
the benefits to the economy of building
some houses
um are not that significant and they are
only transient of course once the once
the estate is built so the
social um the social um
element Council string has mentioned
there's no fbra housing needs survey and
there's no comment specifically from um
housing enabling in terms of the the the
um the the way in list in for fbra
specifically the looking at that
7,668 again if if only 10% of those were
delivered as affordables that would
actually exceed our current waiting list
um and take us a long way towards
2036 so the the social benefit of
granting another nine affordables here
is n actually weighing very
heavily thirdly crucially and that was
the point about the buck all appeal and
so on that if if we build these and we
have these nine affordables we're then
going to it would seem bring largely or
entirely tenants into fbra from
somewhere else but we're going to leave
them with no access to Stow Market
without a car and that 2 and 1 half mile
I think if you look at the picture
that's on screen at the moment thank you
Catherine that tries to show to some
extent how steep that Hill is and having
cycled up it and litter picked up it it
is quite steep actually and um so should
we be really dropping those tenants into
a location like this um rather than
somewhere that is actually sustainable
with access to shops and things like
that so that's the social element then
thirdly the environmental element
the um let's get these in order yeah so
I've talked about slide seven as I've
got it the the the extent of hedge loss
which in my view will be
dramatic uh because it is not a very
thick hedge and in order to push it back
the necessary amount on the crown of the
bend is going to need quite a lot to go
so that's quite a problem the the
quality of the
meadow uh you know it is in land use
terms agricultural yes it's a meadow
which local um people advis has been
unplowed for 40 plus years so it's its
diversity
and biodiversity contribution is quite
considerable as it
is um there's been I think was there a
question about oh no there wasn't that
was the previous one wasn't it so the
Environmental Management
recommendation um is is actually for
refusal because there were no energy or
water proposals and I can't tell you the
page number as I say but you you can
find that in the papers
in detail with the the previous
sustainability officer um Environmental
Management officer
um setting out his recommending for
refusal and then that's been endorsed by
the the new environment management
officer with um with a qualification
alternative of a detailed condition um
which he would like the we not in the
heritage
harm is less than substantial to the
buxo lodge um what has seems to got
missed actually but on slide
52 you can actually see the the other
listed building locally which is the
thatched cottage which was just visible
on that on that slide 52 picture if you
can find that it is pretty much opposite
the
site opposite the the opposite the
access road quite near I think uh we're
going to see that one yes it's the at
the right hand end it's it's the
yellowy I think that's the
one I think it's either that I think it
is that one actually but it might
be it might be the next one I think it's
that one and that is that is a grade two
listed thatch Cottage and it is opposite
the the the site entrance pretty much
yeah so those are the those are the
three elements of sustainability which
clearly in my view are not
delivering uh much benefit to out offset
the harm such as the harm to the listed
building and it
setting um so my conclusion is that in
terms of the mppf um and the current
reality of of The Village's lack of
services this is no longer a sustainable
location and so minimal harm to you know
minimal benefit to outweigh the
identified harm which is a harm to
Heritage but also to biodiversity and
Landscape thank
you thank you very much for that John
thank you um I'll go down the
list um to ask if um people would like
questions so first of all councelor
Casten no questions thank you
chair councelor
gold um no questions for me chair but uh
to to thank the counselor for uh I found
his contribution very helpful thank you
indeed yes thank you councelor Barry
Humphries
no comments thank you councelor
melon uh no questions thank you chair
councelor
Norris uh no questions from me either
thank you councelor
Stringer no questions chair thank you
councelor War boys no questions
chair thank you and myself I don't have
any questions um so thank you very much
indeed we will now move on to the
debate and I will go around again in
alphabetical order everybody will have
the opportunity to speak their thoughts
and when the last person has spoken with
that if anybody wants to make a
recommendation they can advise me on the
pain to the side so first of all
councelor Casten what would you like to
say regarding this
issue thank you very much chair just to
confirm we're in debate
now yes indeed we are in debate um
so issues with this is buckel Lodge 64 M
now to the nearest house I think that's
a um that's a good distance with
especially with the the covering that
they've got the Hedge um I don't think
that they'll be disturbed uh very much
if at all by the houses um the shop
closing and the um the changes to the
sustainability of this is um it's it is
a real shame but 2 and 1 half miles to
Stow Market is is less distance than the
village where I grew up from a shop um
and um there's there there's a lot of
provision in stay Market it's a shame
I'd like to see the buses come back
that's obviously not for the planning
committee to um discuss now but um I
think it is a it is a big shame that
they have lost that bus service but I
think it does to me come down as
sustainable um it also to me this is
classic infill looking at it it's the a
if you look at the shape of the village
it it it it to me it does look like
there's a bit missing that we're um we
would be filling here um shame that it's
not 35% affordable it's um I can
understand why the calculations have
been made to less than that cuz we we
don't go over 35 it's
um but that that is a shame but it's
nice to see affordable beside the open
space instead of beside the road or
beside anything that's going to be noisy
and a less desirable place to live so um
pleased with that um it there's a there
is it does sound like there's a speed
problem on that road quite a severe one
um the um
the the sort of speeds that have been
talked about I think um they people want
to um get very um quick quickly deal
with those kind of speeds especially
outside of school um I think that's
something that can be handled and can be
dealt with as a lot of um villagers do
deal with um speed Problems by different
methods um so yeah finally the um The
Meadows not been plowed for 40 years but
um what I would wonder is whether it's
been sprayed because plowing yes that
does get rid of a lot of species um but
in the um picture that we've been
looking at it's very yellow it looks
like the um that Google Maps has been
taken around May or June time um where
I'm surprised how yellow that field of
grass is whether it's it could have
potentially had a hay cut off it earlier
or it may have been sprayed but it's the
spraying I think that would be the um
serious issue more than the um more than
the plowing of it but um I'm going to
listen to um the debate um make sure
that I'm not missing anything and um
yeah thank you very much
chair well that's very helpful and
particularly from a farmer that's also
very useful to hear all that
information um so um we move on to uh
counseling gold would you like to um
pass your comments please yeah thank you
ch um I'm I'm just concerned about
sustainability of of this site I I hear
what councilor Cen says about the the
distance The Stone Market isn't too
great but it's it's it's very sad to see
uh a settlement which is on one hand
growing but it's on the other hand its
facilities uh diminishing and the fact
that there is bus route the the school
is is is full um as well as the uh is
highways issues uh give me concern for
this proposal uh and the officer uh said
that there are no allocated numbers
against this site and it does rather
look like uh a simple neatening of the
settlement boundary uh rather than uh
any uh real strong argument uh about
growth on that side so my fundamental
concern with this is about its
sustainability thank
you thank you for that um councelor
Humphries
please Madam chair thank you um yeah I'd
like to concur with um Council cast on a
couple points the main one being
location this is a natural infi position
it looks right when you look at it from
a map um doesn't mean it's right but it
looks right um there are a few things
though that
um sort of still stick with me and one
is the the harm or the potential harm to
the lodge um I think that Still Remains
and unless there's condition which would
come on to I guess if we went to a
proposal um to actually maintain the
screens along the southwestern and
Western edges I think that harm would
remain and I think a simple condition
could actually plate the people in the
lodge and reduce that that that level of
harm and might actually satisfy the
heritage off some more um I think it's
great news that they moved the um the
whole site effectively back to at least
64 M that's considerable distance
actually and you got green space between
it and the lodge but I just think that
screening would offer that extra
protection um the debate really I
suppose what's deemed a short distance
and maybe the officers could help out in
a moment but um it's 2 and a half to 2.6
miles a short distance in my world it is
um it's walkable it's cyclable however
um Council Matson made a really good
point it's not the hill that's the issue
because Hills are good for Fitness so
don't don't discount Hills it's the road
that's the issue so walking along that
road having done it myself and running
it um is really dangerous it's quite a
busy road and it will get more busy with
time so that's my one concern with the
sustainability aspect of it and the
ability to walk in Stow Market however
cycling wouldn't be an issue uh nor
driving actually uh if that's your
choice um the school is another issue
that's 2 miles from uh the center of
great finra to the new high school and
my question going back to so maybe the
office could pipe in at some point um my
concern would be that that's two miles
along a busy road what's this school bus
provision uh into stone Market from fbra
does it exist or would it exist um
because I think that's quite important
and the parish council talk about the um
the over subscribing of the doctors in
stone Market but I don't see any report
within the document that sort of um
answers that question really as to
whether it is over oversubscribed or not
and there are numerous doctors well at
least two surgeries in Stow market and
so that would be nice to know the
economic benefit and this is where we do
the balancing bit against the harm uh to
the books or Lodge the economic benefit
the important thing to remember on that
it's not just about great fimber it's
the area around it so Stow Market is 2.6
miles away no how many houses in great
fbra Stone Market would benefit um so
with Hadley to a degree because there no
people shop there and also you've got
another local club which is the shepherd
and dog which is about one and a half
miles away from great fimber and you've
got the cafe G Lakeside both would
actually benefit economically from this
development as would the pub in great
fimber it might open more who knows
that's that's subjective
um I think that's pretty much it the the
bus side of we discussed it's a shame um
it'd be great if it comes back if it
gets funding but on balance um I think
that actually economic benefits outweigh
the potential harm to book or Lodge and
I believe the lodge can be further
mitigated by ensuring we have that
screen along the western Southwestern
Edge and I and I um applaud the fact
that we're getting more affordable
houses that's a great thing they're my
comments thank you councelor Humphries
and we come now to councelor melon if
you would please thank you
yeah thank you chair um so just I mean a
few points to make I
think the most critical one for me is
the fact that our heritage team uh on
page 37 of the papers do not support
this proposal uh whatever um mitigation
we've we've sort of managed to negotiate
in terms of moving the buildings further
away from the lodge that that um hasn't
been accepted um and having s turned
down a proposal largely on Heritage
grounds this morning um we need to sort
of hold on to that issue um the and
clearly the Environmental Management
officer are not very happy about it
either um the Crux of the matter here
with fimber is the fact that it's it was
a primary Village it's in the new plan
it's going to be be a hinten village
it's lost so many of the uh facilities
and inevitably people are going to be
dependent on a car to get into stone
Market um and we just have to decide
whether that makes it an unsustainable
location or not to my mind it would tend
to uh indicate that it's an
unsustainable location um so that's um
that's my feeling on it at this stage of
the debate thank
you thank you for that uh councelor
melon and now councelor Norris
please thank you madam chair uh
councelor melon has just um mentioned
the concern on sustainability I also
have um I don't think the site in itself
is truly sustainable to be frank
actually um I also have a number of
other
concerns uh Des site being outside the
existing settlement
boundary although these settlement
boundaries is proposed to be
recited in the draft updated joint local
plan the inclusion of this particular
site within the settlement boundary is
disputed by the local Paris council with
their
submission um there are also other
matters such as flood risks identified
by suffer County counc floods and water
section on page
33 uh the adverse comments
by suffer preservation Society on page
35 and the lack of any support which has
just been
mentioned referenced to by counselor
melan uh by the Heritage team on pages
37 and
38 and obviously also the highway safety
issues that have been mentioned uh
excessive speeds on the road adjacent to
the site the entrance to the site being
on Crown of a Bend
um I would also refer to page 57 on this
aspect of Highway
Safety
um and I'm a little mystified as to why
so much is tending to be put upon the
classification of being a primary
Village when things have moved on
somewhat uh having lost the local shop
and the local bus service us
so I personally am minded not to support
this application but I will listen to
the rest of the debate thank
you thank you for that uh councelor
norce um I've got one or two people that
I can bring in on this just before we go
I'm sorry counselor string this always
seems to happen but I'm sure it will
benefit you um first of all can I ask Mr
isbel just to um pass a comment or two
and then I'd like to bring in um
Katherine Hae on um an issue there so Mr
isbel
please thank you chairman yeah um just
to come back on on uh a couple of points
to clarify the point about jlp the jlp
is a draft document so we all know that
it's it's it's it's a draft which is
under review and scrutiny by members and
others uh and I imagine as with any
document like that you prepare it at a
at a particular point in time and uh the
world moves on it's probably also true
that the view taken around that
assessment of this Village May well take
account of uh paragraph 78 of the nppf
looking at uh how collections of
settlements works together and we
obviously know that uh finra has a
primary score which is uh is is
certainly an asset even if it does not
have a a wider Suite of these things so
it may be that the policy team in in
designating this Village as they have
done uh have taken a view about its its
relative spacial separation from Stow
Market uh it's its facilities such as
they are including the schooling
including the pub um you know and and a
development management committee is not
really the place to to to to get to the
bottom of why the jlp has designated
this these ways but I'm fairly confident
that that members have that opportunity
uh elsewhere so I wouldn't want to say
too much other than to say uh you know
that that the fact of of of a line on a
proposed plan can be subject to change
and I would give it very limited weight
personally as as as a fact um the
council noris did talk about flood risk
and can I just say as is quite usual um
at the present point in time that's uh
that's included on the recommendation as
a matter to be
resolved uh It's Not Unusual I think for
applicants to uh wish to resolve uh the
technical details of that which can be
quite expensive once they they know that
they are uh that their their scheme is
likely to be acceptable in the round so
uh the the first recommendation is that
uh on page well bear with me one second
page 51 I think it is includes a
requirement that they provide surface
water drainage so I think the flood RIS
thing is a technical detail which can be
addressed uh the point around self
preservation Society Heritage comments
and this Deb building impact I think
ultimately are are a matter of choice uh
and one must draw one's own conclusions
and uh hear the public benefits of
delivering a number of dwellings rather
than delivering one one dwelling are you
know materially different and and to
that extent
uh it's important to have regard to the
fact that that land Supply is is is is
approached commonly as and I think the
parliament's used in our policy team is
a flaw not a ceiling so um K I leave it
there for the moment
chairman thank you for that and may I
also bring in Katherine who wanted to
pass a comment um regarding the Heritage
although I do know we have got tan there
as well thank you yeah I think Phil um
covered it off really the the Heritage
um harm in this instance compared to the
the previous application that was heard
this morning the the main difference is
that was for for one dwelling Alone um
whereas this is obviously for 28
dwellings and this also has affordable
um and therefore the public benefits
that provided by this scheme are
considered um in planning judgment to
outweigh the harm um proposed
furthermore um see slide 55 I can get it
back up if necessary um that does show
uh the Landscaping that is currently
proposed in terms of Hedges and trees
along that western boundary so that
would be one un approved plan but then
condition to ensure that that hedro and
that Landscaping particularly on that
Western Edge was obviously maintained
and also delivered um as well so I think
that was all I had to add other than the
um issue with relation to accidents and
um obviously the dangers of the road I
do have a crash map slide which shows
that there have been obviously a couple
but there's it's not considered that
there are any major accident um sites
within that locality they're all been
slight yes thank you for that update and
I think um Philip Isbell and Katherine
have covered Tegan's area so I hope and
unless we have any more further
questions you're happy with that and so
we will move on to can Stringer who's
been waiting patiently there uh
councelor Stringer
please thank you thank you chair can you
hear
me yes that's a bit clearer than before
actually good good good good good good
I've been working you must be walking
around the room or something not at all
not at all uh I'm sitting very patiently
um right let's let's have a little look
at this one I think really really hits
at the heart of the national planning
policy framework uh and actually I have
to say having looked at this in huge
detail
the more I see the more I think it
doesn't actually quite tilt the balance
in favor of it uh and it is it hovers
around whether this is a sustainable
location I get the point about there was
an appeal for a single house that was
further away but I'm certain in an
appealing one single dwelling is vast
different to a major development and
this is a major development on our scale
and certainly for the scale of a village
such as great fbra so I think we need to
treat this with a lot of care and
attention uh I'm not certain this is a
sustainable location for a significant
development like this uh I really don't
uh given what's changed in between the
designation and today there's a couple
of other challenges as well of course it
is only a mere two and a half miles away
from from Stow Market but without a
dedicated cycle route or footpath uh
walking along a very busy uh at times
narrow road where it Narrows up for a
bridge and there's a few Wiggly bends
and stuff so there's some issues about
that and it's
connectivity I also think uh and
normally when we get these we get an
outline and then we get the detail The
Helpful thing about this one we've got
all of the detail up front because it's
a full application and actually even
with the full application even if this
was in a sustainable location as ever I
have serious issues the design of those
9.6 meter high buildings dwarfing those
buildings on the other side of the road
uh I I don't normally ask a question
unless I know the answer the the
buildings on the other side of the road
are are Circa 6 meters tall there's
houses on the other side of the road 9.6
MERS tall and there will be an open
Vista across that Valley to these
buildings they will look awful and not
in keeping with the character of this
settlement so I I have issues with that
as well I think we need to re really
careful about just assuming because it
says affordable housing that that is a
social tick it's a plus if given there's
no local housing need survey and what
we've used is the data from across the
whole of three districts which will mean
quite a lot of towns uh it could easily
mean that the people that end up living
in the flats are from Urban locations
and here they'll be in a rural location
with no Health Care no walking route on
a footpath no cycle way into the nearest
town little hope of employment no shop
and they won't even be able to get their
children in the local school because
it's full they'll have to be bust
somewhere else that to me is the perfect
definition of unsustainable development
so I I certainly have made my mind up
about this one I think now I've heard
more and more of the information I
certainly won't be supporting this
application in its present form chair
thank
you
thank you for that uh councelor Stringer
and now we move on to councelor warboys
please thank you uh I think I must agree
with Council stringer's comments in
particular the uh the notion of
sustainability and the appeal where one
house could be considered sustainable 28
houses is of a very different
magnitude uh
um I appreciate a great deal of thought
has gone into the integration of
affordable housing but I don't think the
argument has really been proved that
there is a need locally for affordable
housing and by locally I I mean great
fber itself the parish council itself is
concerned that there's already been sort
of existing
development and this 24 development
dwell in development opposite the
proposed site was not
sustainable um I appreciate Council Go's
remarks about it's not really a sort of
uh identifying this site is is really a
neatening of the
boundary um and I disagree that it's a
classic infill site I think this
is a process of suburbanization you have
a rural Village and in rural villages
internal in terms of design the internal
spaces are very important and I think
this substantial Meadow which has a huge
amount of potential as a for
biodiversity is is really important as
an open space and that brings me on to
the uh officer Chen's comments this is
medium level of less than substantial
arm which is is quite significant I
think you know to the Heritage asset
that Meadow alongside the listed
building is really important with
regards to its setting and I think the
um moving the development
60 4 meters or in real terms 200 odd
feet is is a bit arbitrary it doesn't
necessarily
really take into account the the
significance of that open space uh um
the lack of the lack of a bus route is
really important I I can see this really
as as becoming a a dormatory development
rather than a sort of um something which
should really have impact on the a
positive way on the local
community thank you for that counselor
um well I shall say a little bit now um
I I do listen to all of what you've said
um and I think there there are there's a
great Balancing Act to be had here um
I'm never happy about saying about the
public benefits bringing the work for
the construction workers because as
councelor mat said it's
transient um I hear what he says about
the the road and other members saying
about the road being dangerous and the
speed limits um I I'm presuming that the
speed limits I correct me if I'm wrong
but I think it was that they are
speeding within a speed limit um
designation and unfortunately that comes
down to driver um attitudes and the
police however it doesn't make it any
safer for children going to
school um I think it's a great shame
that the the shop has closed There's No
Buses um the primary school I mean what
usually happens is children grow up and
they move on and the spaces do become
available but there could be a log Jam
there um I think councelor Stringer
would be a helpful one to us to help
being a District counselor for the
school buses but that's probably another
story another
day um I think um the comment of the
Heritage I read the papers too and there
were the objections there and we've all
got flowcharts of how that works but I
hear what was said regarding the one
single house and
these um I think this is quite a
difficult one actually um because also
comments people are making regarding the
housing need people don't need it in
finra in planning we have to look at
planning for the whole district and if
we can get local people to use the local
houses then obviously that's a great
benefit um there was comment that the uh
space standards in the affordable homes
could be adjusted so I would welcome
that and so we would need a condition on
that but um this one is quite a
difficult one to balance so I've made my
comments there now and I'll just await
for any further reaction from the
members of the team thank
you councelor melon you would like to
make a
proposal yes thank you chair um bearing
in mind the the Heritage uh problems the
unsustainable location and the lack of
evidence of local need I would like to
propose that this application is
refused and would you like to amplify on
that and also put in the policies for us
that can help um make this um a proposal
in planning terms accurate thank
you uh in terms of to the Heritage uh
concerns I mean these have been set out
in in the papers by the uh the relevant
Department um there's uh harm to the
setting of of the the lodge um the
um the the issue of sustainability I
think is is to do with uh the lack of
local facilities um which designated
great fimber as a as a
primary
Village um and really do not any any
longer apply particularly the lack of a
bus
service um it seems to me that um people
living here will be totally dependent on
a car no one is going to be walking into
Stow Market you might possibly cycle
there but you're not going to do that
with your shopping um coming back up
that hill um and then again the the lack
of a uh uh local need of for for
affordable housing being identified
we've only got figures for across the
whole district and therefore um we don't
have evidence that great fimber needs
the uh affordable
homes I hope that hope that's enough to
be going on with uh well not really no
um I mean that last point that you've
made I have said that planning should be
for the whole of the district but what
I'm looking for are policies and um you
know a little bit more you can't just
use use words when you're wanting to
make a proposal I wonder um there's
somebody sitting in the background there
liking to Second this um but we need
things like you know is it against the
policy cs1 CS2 or what what policies are
we using because they are referred to in
the papers I think we need to be
cautious because you know the officers
are recommending approval and we need to
sort of make it clear for
them can I refer to paragraphs 78 of the
mppf
um housing should be located where it be
where will enhance maintain the
Vitality of rural communities planning
policy should identify opportunities for
villages to grow and Thrive especially
with they will support local
Services uh and it seems to me that that
just doesn't fit with this this
development in terms of local Services
being
available y that's a good start that's
very helpful um let's see what uh
councelor Str
he wishes to Second this and what to
assist you thank
you thank thank you chair uh right yes
also I feel this development is contary
to poliy CS2 which restricts development
in the countryside to Define categories
this is uh defined as Countryside also
uh hp1 and gp1 about poor design and it
being in keeping with local character I
certainly feel dwellings at 9.6 meters
tall is not in keeping with a rural
location like
this equally uh just wanted to address
chair you mentioned about the whole of
the district in terms of affordable
housing I think that is the point mids
has uh
7,668 dwellings already approved as of
January 2020 the affordable element of
those is Circa 900 there's only 663
people on the waiting list that's one
and a half houses per person on the
waiting
list uh I'm not going to argue with you
counselor but what we need to do are
those all deliverable have you got every
one of those down that are deliverable
and that's the Crux of the matter but I
think what we really need to do at the
moment is to take time out um to try and
pull together something of what we think
you want um and see if we can get
somewhere near um to something suitable
that will um will satisfy the the the
reasoning that you're wanting to stop
this so what I'm asking is um we can
have time out now so I wonder if um
Robert you can time out all officers and
the legal side um pull together
something here um to yeah should I set
what time should um oh um if I set a
time of um 38 minutes so can I come in
at
this yeah could if I could just come in
I mean typically in these sort of
situations what we have done in the past
is five minutes to uh reflect on on on
reasoning um between the proposer and
seconder with officers so that we we um
understand what's What's um being
described there's some policies on the
table to to to that I understand there
are some issues I think I'd probably
want to pursue would it be appropriate
for myself to have a separate
in these unusual circumstances have a
separate Skype conversation with the
proposer and second of the motion whilst
you're uh whilst you adjourn the meeting
and then sort of use that to um assist
them on on on professional matters that
they can then uh come back to you with
something most appropriate I'm quite
happy with that so if Robert could
adjourn the meeting and Philip set that
up at the moment if Madam chair if I may
I'll just butt in again say well because
we're in Uncharted Territory here in and
members of the public listening to this
on YouTube might not be aware but in a
normal dare I call this a normal
committee meeting that we hope to be
back to before very many most longer we
this you you we would adjourn the
meeting and we'd physically go outside
and invite to help the proposer and
seconder and that we're we're just doing
that virtually so it's perfectly proper
and
lawful yes absolutely um I think that
was a very helpful
explanation so on that if you just mute
the
um the committee meeting for is Robert
and let philli with the in um and the
proposer and seconder have that short
discussion so so what I'll do chairman
perhaps is a question of timing and
probably if I if we if we allow a
quarter an hour that will be sensible
and helpful for me maybe 10 minutes um I
will separately Skype uh councelor
Stringer councelor melan and and Ian so
that we have uh can have that separate
conversation right okay happy with that
and you will inform me afterwards when
you get back to it I'll come come back
to you just as soon as I can yes yeah
thank you very much thank
you
right CH we're
back right someone's having a cup of tea
so um Mr isbel did you want to sort of
spell out what was the result of your
meeting thank you uh yes thank you
chairman yes uh councilors melan and
Stringer uh have discussed with me their
concerns and and their issues and we
reviewed this uh uh together with uh uh
Mr depre so uh as things stand I
understand there to be two proposed
reasons uh which councilor melan and
Stringer uh wish to put to committee
first one concerns sustainable
development and I'll read this for batim
so that uh there there's Clarity for the
meeting the proposed development lies
outside the settlement boundary of Great
finra and The Proposal would be within
the countryside contrary to policiy cs1
and CS2 of the core strategy and local
plan policy
H7 having regards to the absence of
services and Facilities within great
finra it is foreseeable that future
occupants would be relied upon the
private car with limited opportunity to
maximize sustainable Transport Solutions
and the development therefore fails to
comply with the requirements of
paragraphs 8 11 and 103 of the nppf and
the presumption in favor of sustainable
development having regard moreover to
the harm identified to the historic
environment on this basis The Proposal
is not considered to form sustainable
development within the criteria set out
by the nppf The Proposal is therefore
contrary to paragraphs 81 103 193 and
196 of the nppf and contrary to policies
cs1 CS2 and CS5 the core strategy but
moreover contary to policies fc1 and FC
1.1 of the core strategy focused review
and policies H7 and hb1 of the mids
suffk local plan so that's the
sustainable development reason which
councilors melon and Stringer have
discussed with me and then as regards
the question of this building and the
design matter
um the wording that uh we have arrived
that is as follows uh for a further
reason for refusal here the proposed
development would be Suburban in
character and of inappropriate scale
design and mass relative to the adjacent
streetcape despite its location within a
small and traditionally linear Village
the inappropriate overly varied and
uninformed architecture of the dwellings
hard landscaping and Boundary treatment
contribute to this unsympathetic scheme
which fails to reflect local character
The Proposal would therefore fail to
protect preserve or enhance the
character and appearance of the locality
and therefore setting and significance
of the surrounding Heritage assets which
would result in less than substantial
harm to the setting and significance of
the listed buildings and which are not
outweighed by public benefits having
regard to the overall application
circumstances on that basis The Proposal
is contrary to the requirements of
section 66 of the planning listed
building conservation areas act 1990 and
the principles of the nppf paragraphs
193 uh 196 uh and contrary to policies
CS5 of the core strategy and policy hb1
of the mids local plan now chairman
those are the reasons that were put by
two members uh I did mention to them
that were members minded to refuse this
it would be appropriate for committee
also to deal with a matter of flooding
because that's at the moment a matter
which officers believe can be delegated
for further resolution uh so I would
also suggest that uh if members are
minded to uh take a vote on this as they
will need to uh that we would add a
further reason for refusal uh which is
the application fails to demonstrate
that development would not risk harm by
reason of surface water flooding having
regard to the insufficient information
to demonstrate a viable surface water
drainage strategy and that itself is
contrary to paragraphs 8 148 163 and 165
of the npf and policy CS3 of the core
strategy now chairman you will obviously
need um councilors melon and Stringer to
uh agree to that as an amendment to
their proposal but um as an officer uh
advising committee I would suggest that
would be a prudent thing to do thank you
chairman thank you well I didn't managed
to write that down um but I wrote a few
policies down um but I would like to
first of all come to count melon are you
happy that the additional three relating
to the flooding is added to your refusal
please yes chair I'm happy with that and
councelor Stringer a seconder are you
happy with that yeah more than happy
thank you chair thank you for that um
so we now have a proposal and a seconder
and we need to go around a second time
time before we take the
vote so with what's on the table before
us um if anybody wants to um make any
further comment can I come to First
councelor
Casten thank you very much chair um so
with this unsustainable um development
side of this um I just feel that people
don't always want to um live in Stow
market yet this is a village right on
the edge of Stow Market with all the
opportunities to um use the um services
and everything within Stow Market I can
understand if um I can understand that
there isn't a
shop here but I still think it's a very
good position for um tenants of um
affordable housing and Council houses to
um to be that close to services but but
still in a village um the the 6m houses
outside the development I 6 m is a very
um very um low roof line the um I I
can't measure it but I can look on
Google Earth and I know that a um a
Lor's 5 m Telegraph pole I should think
would be over um six or seven and the
telegraph poles look a lot lower than
the houses so I'm not sure if this
information that we're
using is good enough to make this
decision with but um I'll carry on and
listen but I'm um I'm at the moment I
can
understand why counselors are looking at
this
sustainability and these other issues um
I for me it's not enough to um to make
me go with this proposal but thank you
I'll wait to hear from the other
counselors thank you councelor Casten
that was very helpful councelor
gold uh nothing to add except that I'm
I'm minded to go with with the proposal
thank
[Music]
you thank you um councelor
Humphries Madam chair thank you yeah
it's a difficult one this um and I get
the point that councel caston's made
actually that this in my mind Still
Remains sustainable and I'll come on to
why because it supports the local area
not just specifically great thra but
Stow Market where there are great
Services uh everything on offer and
actually connections to The Wider World
um via the railway system or bus system
so sustainability actually I think
that's is a bit table to be honest with
you because it's only 2 to 2.5 miles
away from the center of Stow market and
it's close to schools I do have an issue
with the dangerous road that leads in
which is the high road which leads down
into Stow Market itself but we are in a
world where people like it or not do use
cars regularly and I would like to hope
there's not enough information in the uh
in the pack that there would be
provision for school buses uh to take
them to Stone Market schools but I'm not
sure where that fits um on the Heritage
side of it um we got to be careful this
isn't similar to the last application
and as it is a separate application
stands on its own so we can draw
precence and information from every
application we've ever seen but we have
to judge this on its merits um and I
believe that there are still concerns
actually with the heritage of bucks or
Lodge but they can be mitigated by
conditioning of remaining the retaining
the screening and improving the
indigenous uh trees on the south and
Southwest area so we could mitigate
against it um I don't think there's a
design issue here I don't think there's
a reason to turn it down and uh you keep
talking about a linear Village well in
my mind linear means straight or in line
um now if we go back 70 years you have
got a true state statement that the the
the small village was linear along the
road so absolutely right but in the last
70 years it's been developed and a look
at the areas of the chestnuts pilgrims
way Ash close they're the older
developments we then move further into
into the uh the village itself we got
petty W close fairly new and actually
the size of those buildings is probably
consistent with the ones that are being
proposed for this development so I don't
see the linear approach I think that's a
little bit flawed because just looking
at an the map right now it's circular uh
and I think that's been the case for a
number of years if you move further down
high road to the South there's new
developments there as well on the edge
of the uh the road uh and they're quite
considerably in Heights so again um
there are high buildings not just the 6
meter ones that are you know just
adjacent to that development so I don't
think that's an issue
um let me see another thing local needs
Store Market housing we do need housing
otherwise we wouldn't be building um
Stone Market is an emerging and growing
town it's evolving more businesses um
and people need houses and Council
Caston is absolutely right you may
choose not to live in the center of
Stone Market but just two to two and a
half miles away which is commutable for
many by bicycle which ticks the
environmental uh and sustainable um tick
uh or by car if you so wish um there are
other significant developments in the
area one house uh being particular
particularly close uh less than two
miles away and in terms of supporting
the local environment I still believe
that this is a sustainable location
because the local amenities of Stow
Market are significant and are close
enough to get there by bicycle or by car
and that the benefits this would bring
to the Village of great limbra it may
improve the pub and its economic uh
output but also the local businesses
including shepher and dog Lakeside Cafe
and all the shops Etc within ster Mark
itself um I'm actually minded not to go
with the proposal and sit alongside
councelor Casten for the various reasons
that I
quoted thank you for that and now um we
come on to councelor melon if you'd like
to make further comments please
do uh thank you chair I don't think I
need to say uh much more um so I'll just
leave the proposal to uh be debated
further thank
you thank you for that and councelor
Norris would you like to speak to the um
proposal uh no nothing further to add I
am quite happy with the reasons given
for the recommendation for refusal thank
you and councelor Stringer would you
like to make any further
comments uh no nothing other than just
to reiterate about the sustainability
yes we need uh the right affordable abl
and the right houses in the right places
what and it's a very very difficult
position when we're being offered
affordables here with precious little in
the way of infrastructure to support
these people uh they may be okay but if
they're not it will become unsustainable
and we we're building up problems for
the
future thank you for those comments and
then councelor War boys
please I think it's a very well PHR uh
phrased um proposal I think it reflects
what great fber Parish Council said in
that they're supportive of growth but it
has to be sustainable and of good Dei
design and this development in great
fibra over and above is over and above
what is acceptable and sustainable I
think in the long term we need to look
at resilience in the local
communities and promote good design and
sustainability thank you for that and I
will comment um I think indeed it is a
very difficult one um and I hear
everybody's reasoning for their
thinking but I also think that we've got
this piece of land that will be used for
development in the future and I think
that the officers have tried to work to
fit um appropriate development and
hopefully not damage the area
concerned so I will actually uh not go
along with um councelor stringers and
councelor melon's reasoning but I do
have reservations um in these sort of
situations so um let's go to the vote
now please so councelor uh so Robert
Carmichael would you like to go through
the vote please thank you chair so I'll
do the roll call in the same fashion if
you could please respond with four
against or abstain so first off
councelor
Kasten against the
proposal councelor
G for the
proposal Council
Guthrie against the
proposal counc
humph against the
proposal councelor
melon for the
proposal councel Norris
for the recommendation for
refusal Council
Stringer
for and councilor War
boys for the
proposal so chair I make that five votes
to three in favor of the refusal Mr
DEA I I agree Mr Carmichael five to
three it's the so the the propos the the
resolution is successfully um passed
resolution to
refuse well thank you very much indeed
and um can I just thank all participants
uh to a rather um unusual um planning
meeting but I think we've got the
resolutions um through the correct
process um I would just um like to say
uh a big thank you to everybody in the
background who's worked on this as well
um also the um members were going to
have a uh debriefing on how we've all
done can you just indicate whether
you're happy to continue uh once we've
closed this meeting um because there are
no further matters for the meeting um so
could members just indicate they're
happy to continue thank
you chair just one more thing um we just
to report there aren't any site visits
as per the final item on the
agenda yes absolutely there are no site
visits thank you so the meeting the
official meeting is now closed thank you